[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Jean
Marco soresi an incredible incredible
comedian and person who I met at just
for last Montreal this year and was
absolutely Blown Away here's a little
taste of our conversation I think I
think my dad is
there's just a disconnection he's not
close with the family his father left uh
started a second family and I think oh
his father
was Italian and I do believe that his
connection to being Italian is the part
of his father he could still love
despite having you know the such
resentment towards his his father
himself I wish we had a trophy here
because that's some good
so much goodness to get to guys just a
couple things to plug here up top I want
to say I want I want to say that I'm
going to be on tour thanks to everybody
that came to Atlanta Charlotte
Washington DC uh coming up is Vancouver
that's this weekend go to petehomes.com
for tickets to Vancouver followed by
Grand Rapids Grand Rapids excuse me San
Diego New Orleans Dallas Houston
Milwaukee Madison Royal Oak Michigan
Minneapolis Minnesota New York New York
and Bridge uh Ridgefield excuse me
Ridgefield Connecticut the shows have
been incredible this hour is very very
special to me it's so fun to perform it
means so much when weirdos come out and
support so it'll be great to see you
guys on the road like I always say
petehomes.com for tickets all of that
and if you like this show why not try
Pete's pick we just got one pizza pick
up top here this is I'm wearing it
for those of you watching the video you
guys have heard me talk about the Apollo
neuro quite a bit in fact I'm being
visited by my friend Kurt one of my
longest and oldest friends and he is
wearing his Apollo because of course I
gave him an Apollo because I can't stop
telling people what a difference it's
made in my life it's not a watch it kind
of looks like I'm wearing a watch but it
is a piece of wearable tech that helps
your body recover from stress what does
that mean he uses almost sub-perceptual
vibrations to speak to your nervous
system directly through touch it's like
touch therapy that you wear on your
wrist or your ankle that helps you relax
sleep focus and be more productive it is
like a wearable hug for your nervous
system using touch therapy to help you
feel safe and in control the settings
are energy and wake up which is
incredible before a workout you really
feel that one it's like espresso it gets
into your system it gets your heart
beating and pumping and blood moving
it's such a wonderful uh thing when I'm
driving if I feel a little sleepy while
I'm driving I hit the two buttons on my
Apollo run the energy and wake up keeps
me alert I love it social and open is
usually what I have it on while I'm
doing the podcast it's exactly what it
sounds like helps your shoulders relax
and ease into social uh situations with
more grace clear and focused has been
shown to combat some of the symptoms of
ADD I use that when I'm writing when I'm
studying when I'm reading wonderful way
to get your body into that mode rebuild
and recover after something stressful
I'm always in fact I'm a little bit sick
right now so mine is currently rocking
rebuild and recover all the way to relax
and unwind and sleep and renew so
helping you rest helping you meditate
helping you focus helping you wake up
it's incredible it's like finding the
fuse box to your body and you can see
everything labeled and you can turn
certain things on and certain things off
it has made such a chemical free
difference in my life meaning it's not
something that you a prescription drug
or something that you need to take it's
something that your body can understand
and it just lulls you into that state or
jazzes you into a heightened state it is
not woo-woo I always like to point this
out it was developed by a neuroscientist
and a board-certified psychiatrist
who've been studying the impacts of
chronic stress in humans for nearly 15
years and Apollo's effects on stress
sleep cognitive performance and Recovery
have been proven in multiple clinical
trials in real world studies and they're
doing new studies all the time the best
way to see if you like it is to give it
a try and you'll be showing your support
of this podcast and showing your body
just a little support we could all use
get 10 off and show your support of the
show go to apollonuro.com weird that's
Apollo n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird for 10
off something special something helpful
something real you can do to help your
body cope with stress and show your
support of the show alright everybody
that's it hope to see you on the road go
to petehomes.com to come see me do stand
up and in the meantime enjoy this chat
with the incredible John Marco soresi
and check out his podcast it's called
the downside and enjoy this podcast
called you made it weird all right get
into it look at this he de-laces I love
high tops but they take too long so do
we love them
I mean if a shoe has one strike against
it do we still love it like can you have
a shoe that you love that you're like
there's something I hate about this shoe
but I still love it and if the thing is
that putting it off
oh is this for me you if you're a little
low energy that's Magic Mike it is one
of our sponsors but it's because I love
them and then I reached out give it a
shake give it a shake give it a shake
get a little much in it people people
are tired of hearing me say this just a
little caffeine but it's good for your
brain I'll take it you're gonna love it
I'll give you some to go a little little
parting gift
you can also yeah sure it's delicious
let's go back to our hot riff you can
just check it man it's it's a chugging
it's a shot it's a shot it's like a yeah
yeah do it properly now look at the
camera and say I love it can you say
this is John Marco this is your Market
thank you I just needed help with your
name I'm not getting paid for the
sponsorship and it's still good yeah
yeah they'll offer you cash to reuse
that please yeah
I have a teeth whitening commercial
it's a 10 I did it 10 years ago
and sorry there you go they paid me in
teeth whitening products oh and I was a
young actor in New York I signed a
10-year contract I got paid in tooth
whitener wait facts because that's what
like my mother thinks commercials are
like you get paid in the product yeah
you just got paid in the product yes
yeah just six let me rephrase that so
you didn't get paid and they gave you
product yes because whenever I see like
I I had a driver
uh the other day because I've been
traveling too of course and he was
telling me that he was on The Price is
Right because he heard me on the phone
discussing Show Business and I think he
was like there was like a slight dick
measuring yeah it really was like I did
I didn't I I had to take the call of
course but there were things of course
things were said and this guy did not
know who old homes he was because old
homsy I'm like a spy plane I'm right
below that radar nobody knows old homes
and then after he hears old homes he'd
be like blah blah blah blah blah he goes
he's just out of nowhere goes like I was
on The Price is Right and of course what
do you say what do you what do you say
when someone says I was on The Price is
Right I won the showcase showdown you
say how much did you win yeah what was
the price yeah what was the price what
was the hot tub that he returned sure
because it was too small and I'm like
too small is this a fat joke for you
like are you yourself is this a self-fat
joke sfj is this an sfj he was a it was
a bigger fellow he wasn't but I guess
this was a tiny ass heads up I don't
know know was it the Drew carriers or
the Bob Barker years I feel like Bob
Barker is a hot tub was like something
you put your feet in yes and now we're
like give me something I can sleep in
yeah yeah yeah like I hot tubs are over
I I've stayed in a couple places with
hot tubs you use it once you get too hot
five minutes later you go a regular bath
is fine
your regular bath is fine but you're
you're tall the only thing about a hot
tub is the depth oh God but you're tall
oh no I'm saying but I'm saying we
understand the knees go out look at you
and then you turn off the water
because I'm tall soft you're tall skinny
so when I call you string bean
compliment because I go look at that
lowercase L when was your growth spurt
what age I think it's still happening
really I'm an uppercase B is what I'm
saying for sure you're a lowercase L and
I've always envied the lower cases the
Llama people when I lose weight people
go like did you get taller that's what
people say yeah they they think it's
tall I'm like an optical illusion I have
a manager who lost 30 pounds like 10
years ago and people still remember him
heavy sure every meeting I've had with
him starts with a five minute discussion
of how great Dave looks and I'm like
he's looked like this for 10 years sure
you remember you hit save on heavy Dave
yes have you been working out I heard
it's a podcast that you were working out
what is this you have a compliment what
is this a nice thing what is this you're
going I'm glad you accepted my lowercase
L thing because I really okay I didn't
mean it
um I have started because I'm 43 and my
friend James was like if you don't go
into your 50s with muscle you'll just
never have it sure so it was like the
clearance sale on muscles
like because there was a clock on it yes
I was like oh there's a clock on it now
I'm interested what's something you want
to be able to do with your body was
there a moment of like you couldn't open
something and you said [__] dude love
this question this is by the way what's
the name of your podcast the downside if
you want to hear a great interviewer
like this
go to the we believe it
until I start sponsoring them it's going
to be magic mine yeah I'll put you in
touch I mean tell me how you feel in 10
minutes
what if you you die in tennis magic mind
it'll kill jean-marcos you would cut it
out you'd make it work oh yeah would
just get Jeff Goldblum in here please
I've yet to meet him I've yet yes
uh I mean like he's so
um he's velvet he's a velvet person what
I'm about is that he's he's Jewish like
me yeah and that's not what I was saying
because Jeff gold is kind of his own
thing but keep going it's kind of his
own thing but but uh meaning he's not a
classic anything but I think that's it's
what he did with it like if you if you
like Woody Allen you know he stutters
yeah it's not it's not hot you know I
won't describe it as sexy but no but but
but but Jeff took the stutter and and he
made it sexy he took the Jewish stutter
added a little more Glides between it
and and uh I uh I I I don't know but yes
and it's him stuttering and him
stuttering but he does it with a Glide
Allen yes it's a smooth Allen yes I
promise
if I could maybe just get in line here
if I could if I could Ah that's what it
is that's Jeff okay
time I don't a croissants they get stuck
in my throat and uh the uh croissants
they get a little stuck in my throat
and then they say well have whatever you
want Mr Golden we'll go get you anything
this will get you a moisture bread
we will get you a moister bread yes
there's something immediate about gold
Bloom because when you're going uh uh uh
uh any but he's with you he's always
looking at you and he's going uh uh you
get the sense of a high wire act like is
he gonna get it yes there's like I could
be wrong I'm just saying there's like a
and even if he doesn't he's gonna be
happy with the results yeah well
sometimes you fall up the stairs and
here we are and yes get in the elevator
and it's already open what what did he
just say nothing was said something like
that I do I want to see him when he's
angry I just whenever whenever was
almost outwardly like so pleasant and so
intense I'm like there's something in
there when and then you talk to the
assistant or something you're like you
work with Jeff Goldblum and they're like
yeah trust me the Glide goes away when
he's yelling at you yeah in the car he
goes um come over here where the [__] is
my yeah chai latte I said
I'm interested in the gold blue massage
because we're in one incredibly yes yes
but when does it end it's interesting
that these things end Brendan Fraze sure
back in the back in the Limelight there
he is shimmering shining you're doing
great we loved him and uh the mummy and
then oh 30-year break weird I teach f as
the whale
in the whale if they switched roles I
could see that that's the movie that he
came back with fat suit that everyone
everyone's everyone's it's this weird
thing they're excited for Brandon they
don't like the movie and we don't like
the movie people really don't know if I
forget I mean you know when I say we I
mean the general Twitter are we mad at
the movie
because when I saw a preview about a
hefty individual being played by a
non-hefty people are going to be mad
I think it's reasonable squeezable very
soft but Gilbert Grape we we like our
real bigs yes get a real big enough I'm
not trying active opportunities are
there for this person on a skinny suit
and do something else you gotta let her
do it can you please do that on stage
tonight sure the very heavy can't put on
a skinny suit it's not fair there's no
skinny suit did oh I'm sorry I'm a suit
now that's what the Heavies are saying
yeah and this whole time I'm like can I
say Heavies it's is that the new is that
I'm trying I like saw is heavy as
Heavies well technically it's it's
typically is that like a turtle that
people use I'm trying it sure because
you certainly can't say if you if you're
the one to invent the new term for
forever I think I'd have to be quite
heavier sure be like we prefer heavier
yes because getting back to your initial
point when old Petey gets in more shape
I have jokes about being soft and they
don't work quite as well if like when I
was I know what you mean coming out of
quarantine uh shape people were like one
of us and now I'm like I'm soft and
they're like eat [__] maybe anyway MLA
I'm I'm TV fat they're getting it okay
you're getting one of these shits yeah
exactly okay yeah yeah you're no longer
a man of the people no no no uh no no no
I always feel that when I like when I
started stand up I thought I was a
chubby kid or I always thought I had
boobs like early stand-up was like
yeah yeah I had a waiter at Bennigan's
tell me he was a gay waiter uh not
important but sir you'll see where it's
going he said he wanted to titty [__] me
and that night I went home and did uh
push-ups the kind with your legs on the
ground
that'll get you doing something sure I
had when I did shirts versus skins
your response was sure because I know I
know exactly I I had when I was doing
shirts versus skin tell me in middle
school and this kid killed me he went
booby booby give me this kid's name
he's in a rich he's in a rich family
he'll kill us both first Yeah well yeah
I can't be going through lasers to kill
somebody sure I can't be moving all
sorts of crystalline boxes just to get
into somebody's house
people do that with the with the Bitcoin
they're like I'm gonna hire someone to
kill someone that's uh what do you mean
Bitcoins
I can't I just imagine the person's like
oh this is a thing you can buy what I
like the intersection there is a
murderer who also understands
cryptocurrency who's like I'm on The
Cutting Edge of uh crypto well when you
hear about the people get caught you're
like who's not getting caught who didn't
how many murders the berry of Bitcoin we
don't know
yeah we don't know this is the uh this
is the open marriage thing we don't know
the successful ones because they don't
talk about it sure that's a good is that
has that been on your mind of late I'd
love to open up my marriage right now if
you know what I'm saying
too
we don't know each other that well and
I'm really glad you breast standed that
bet sure yes you press that real you're
the real uh-huh I said that when I was
on your Mantra I've been really looking
forward to this oh Oh I thought you said
the titty [__] thing no no but I saw you
in Montreal oh yeah I made you a
Bennigan Twitter in the retelling but it
was you said I wanna today [__] you and
I was like what a weird thing to say to
uh the guy hosting your show I tell
people so so you hosted the new faces
showcase and you went on let me tell the
story let me well don't let's not not
let me tell the part where you go on
because I I have I have nothing but awe
that's right a-w-e baby but so so you
you you hosted both shows there were two
I was on the second yeah and you you
know you were very much the cheerleader
you make everyone feel good you give
everyone a real good pep talk you gave a
strong pep talk your group was more open
to pep talk other years I didn't get a
pep five but your group seemed more like
hey any any words or at least a
frequency tell me tell me what you're
about to say and you you like kind of
after the first group kind of wind it
down you CA we were mostly the second
group and you said guys just so you know
second shows uh it's usually usually
better people are loose it's later
they're a little drunk yeah and then you
went out and hosted the second show and
you came back and you went
foreign they are tired they
they are tired
I think it was a lot of people from the
first show that came back and were like
oh my God it was good so think about
that the second because there was a mood
of like they're tired
not because of you because they were
they were that I think I reached the
point I broke the anxiety went past the
anxiety into [__] it Well jean
the guy that thinks he's the only one
that's ever thought to call you judge
John uh Sean Marco
um you okay so I I hosted more than two
I hosted two that night but I hosted a
whole bunch of new faces showcases and
and I say this with respect to Montreal
but it is a road gig that matters yes
it's a road gig with steaks yes which is
forgive it's part of it I'm clearing my
throat to be like don't ask yourself but
I'm just saying that's a nightmare it's
a nightmare to do a gig that isn't ideal
you know what else Gordon he did great
on Gordon I'm watching it going [__]
this audience what is this audience that
was that was you did great you did great
and just like every agent and manager
told you I'm sure they were like that
was phenomenal you played it perfectly
it looks like a great set comic to Comic
I'm watching and it's the same very
similar to the set you did in Montreal
you know some of the same bits yeah yeah
I'm just going like what is this and
then you danced and they clapped for
that I was like this is a Juiced up TV
audience I'm not saying they're dumb
yeah I'm saying it's the wrong setting
wrong flavor here comes in my opinion
one of the funniest comedians in the
world and I'm like watching facts but in
Montreal similar similar compliment
coming to you it was the end of the show
so it's like it's been 90 minutes plus
of just Channel changing People 7
minutes seven minutes seven minutes
seven minutes and there's a lot of stank
uh and I say this with Lev same my new
face is [__] like when I did new faces
they're stank because it matters yeah
it's not it's not just having Bud Lights
in Chicago and going up in an open like
is this showcase that you're like this
could change my life so that contributes
to the strange air so the audience and
the performers
so by the time you were going up I was
like I remember vividly having the
thought I wouldn't want to be this guy
like I was like I I this is a nightmare
like this show is done I could go out
right now and do my my biggest jokes my
my clothes or whatever you want to say
wouldn't work and you went out and you
were
you just okay I don't know how to say it
other than saying like you were exactly
yourself
authentic you weren't pandering there's
a way to do it where you're like come on
and you whip them into a that's not what
you did you just did an excellent
version of what you do with maybe
slightly higher energy maybe slightly
higher energy to go but your attitude
was if you sit this out and I love this
attitude you're dumb because life is
hard and I'm very good at what I do
that's very kind yeah I oh I was I was a
theater kid so like when I get on those
stages sometimes I'm like oh I can
finally be the size I want to be you
were the size finally because there's a
there's a lot of rooms where sometimes I
feel the audience is like whoa you're
gonna hit us with your your gestures no
that night we all saw theater act I
still can't try I'm not even trying to
say your last name theater acts
crazy it is it's a lot easier than I
than I've been making I've never
in the beginning they said change it to
something more Jewish because you're
gonna they're gonna go the anti-stew it
they they essentially they said okay
they're gonna get a meeting and they're
gonna think Jim Marco's gonna walk in
and then uh jamarco is going to walk in
and they're gonna go oh my God what did
we what do we do meanwhile they got zero
meetings in the entire time but I didn't
change it I like I like I like the
jamarco they wanted like Josh gold
something yeah but we have a Josh we
have Josh we have a lot of Japanese it's
a lie though my name is a lie it's so
Italian people think
um okay look yes you feel Jewish to me
of course you know there are nose juice
what's that you know Jews in the middle
of the country
conscious of them that's well you know
they need a clue right up again right
out the gate or they don't know they
don't know Jews
I'm amazed places that don't know you go
on the road as a Jew and people are they
you have to explain everything from the
beginning
Moses moisture to us and then you go
into it that is hilarious yeah
okay I get it what I was I was gonna
kind of say like I know a lot of Jewish
people my whole life I've known a lot I
went to school in Cambridge
Massachusetts a lot of big Jewish
Community a lot of all the all the kids
in my class most of them were I don't
want to say most but like half of them
were Jewish at least and then there are
some Jewish people that just read
Italian like it's very blurred yes and
you could play Italian I think listen
they've sent me out for for every
Mediterranean European but I think so
but then if I'm with a group of real
Italians you go okay yeah I could have
been on White Lotus I could have been
you know italian-ish yeah italian-ish
but but the new Kenya bear is
italian-ish but but it's it's it's I
think the thing that people think is
Italian is more just like
anxiety or just like add like it's just
circulation well it moves anxiety in an
Italian person an anxiety and a Jewish
person seems to express itself just
slightly differently yes in the body yes
and and I I'm not the authority here you
take this reference well I I that's the
setup I'm gonna sit this play out I just
think that that's why I was able to
think my dad like raised me to believe I
was a hundred percent Italian because he
because he's just he's a liar he's just
a liar and and to the point where that's
like my dad with Irish by the way really
we're from Boston so it was just like so
cool to be Irish he did his uh 23andMe
or whatever and it's like yeah there's a
there's a garnish of cilantro but it's
not exactly what it is and they but he
loves being like but my grandmother's
name was Sullivan and I'm like yeah but
there's also all this other stuff in
there and that's you in Italian I I
would never even do the 23andMe because
I get scared as to how little it might
actually be right but but my my dad I I
when I was a kid I watched I at some
point watched The Godfather so much I
started signing my name first my middle
name is Vincent my dad at some point
said no it's Vincenzo and my mom had to
go no it's not
it's not Vincenzo tell your dad they're
divorced tell your dad to stop lying to
you Vincenzo Vincenzo my channel you got
vincenzo'd your dad was like Italian
pranking you
he's pranking himself he's within his
own like he wants to believe it he
doesn't just want you to believe oh he
wants to believe it where I went to
Italy after college because he said we
had family in Sicily and I was young I
was stupid I got all the way to Sicily
and I finally called my dad I say okay
time to meet the family and he's like I
I can't find I don't know where they are
he cat all the way all the way to Sicily
it was like being catfished by my father
in a way but about my lineage oh no so
this is this is like uh White Lotus
season yes exactly yeah I should have
just been there being like trying to
connect to my roots but you would have
rather remember they find the ladies and
they like kick them out they're like
very inhospitable to them you would have
preferred that
yeah I mean they they could have gone in
with a little more I would have enjoyed
that you you would have like someone
reached out to me on Instagram
uh over covet and they're like we are
they were in Sicily and we're second
fourth cousins removed so it's something
is there there's some kernel of Truth
okay there's a sarazi street there was a
sorezi pasta something but it's far yeah
my great grandpa's name was Luigi though
which I do think is funny right that was
the first joke that I was like where is
this crowd I tell my family we're from a
Nintendo and I'm like it's an Applause
break I don't know what's happening but
that's just that's old homsy if you had
had 300 homesies in that crowd sure
that would have been a shocking if I
came out and there were 300 almost just
clones terrifying
um okay let me you mentioned the
Godfather because my father is also we
don't have I don't know if we have any
Italian maybe a smidge sure maybe just a
little problem he's got the slick back a
little bit just a little bit I don't
know where this hair comes from but uh
very little but my dad is obsessed like
I feel like every dad
with like The Godfather something about
manhood they're slight on Italian
leather shoes uh yeah pasta violence
like by the way these are stereotypes
but these are the things that my father
seems to like this like when Joe Pesci I
saw a good Fellas when I was way too
young to see Good Fellas it was one of
those horrible memories yeah you know my
dad's watching it he's probably tying
one on what was the scene that [__]
you up like the where there's the body
in the trunk and then they and then he
just goes back and casually stabs him I
know that's like not a big deal if
you've seen a thousand a hundred
thousand murders yes but if it's your
first one and it's Joe something about a
little Joe Pesci kind of waddling up and
stabbing somebody you're like he looks
like he looks like a cartoon character
yeah nothing safe if Joe Pesci and he's
not to say he's not
I also [__] know him from
[__] home a goddamn alone here
comes [__] home alone in a shark
skinned suit and stabs stabs a tied up
and bound person your dad should have
told you it was like home alone too
where they actually catch him they
actually do that's what they wanted to
do yeah yeah that's what they wanted
that's what if you think about it that's
what they wanted to do to Kevin yeah
they wanted to murder Kevin he murdered
them 10 times over if we really follow
the physics of some of these prayers oh
Kevin murdered them for I mean if I was
I don't but a stand-up bed I want to see
that movie where Kevin hits him in the
head with a pipe and then he's dead and
then his little kid has a dead body to
dispose of worse he's kneeling by a
dying body going like this prank
I'm sorry I thought the Skittles on the
stairs was funny and he's like
swallowing his tongue and then the old
man with the shovel calls the cops on
him and goes like I saw it all
on the witness stands the lady covered
in Birds I'm blending and they try they
try him as an adult because you know
you're so skilled he's really a smart
boy yes yes he had that slow motion
machine that made him sound like an
adult let's try him as an adult the talk
boy why did I act like I couldn't
remember the name talkboy yes is that a
movie talkboy is the name of the Walkman
that he uses to speed up for sure it's
prominent speaking of magic mind product
placement talkboy is the magic mind of
Home Alone two credit card you got it
that you know that part I I you don't
have to pretend
sort of it's how he orders food and
stuff okay yes I do remember it yes I do
because he has his dad's credit card but
he sounds like a you know like a
middle-aged woman all little boys sound
like middle-aged women
if I'm to be believed I haven't I
haven't spoken in New York you don't run
into many middle-aged middle-aged boys
sure or middle-aged women in this
industry forgive the ref I'm talking
about when I was 11. I I would always
call like Sears to see if they had
things that were like in the Sears
catalog they'd always call me ma'am now
did it really [__] you up when you were
at that age like did it bother you it
did I'd go thanks ma'am and I'd hang up
the phone like really like even if it
was a man you'd say thanks ma'am yeah
you feel the shame you know what's funny
is he if it was a woman
they just thought I was angry at
something else maybe I got stung by a
bee I hope it was a man because that was
my point I was like well clearly you're
a man but I'm calling you ma'am because
you called me a man and I'm a man ma'am
I had long hair so the the one time I
was misgendered I was doing
trick-or-treating with some girls that I
probably had like a crush on yeah and I
was a hippie and I went to a door and a
woman said oh what are you supposed to
be a little boy and I was like oh my God
they thought I was pretending I was this
was a costume and it was it I mean
the idea to know that that not only you
look like you're pretend like what is
that what does that even mean what are
you supposed to be what are you a little
boy
we I'm certainly not an expert in it but
isn't that the whole thing like what are
you supposed to be like culture will
tell like a tie-dye shirt too I couldn't
have been wearing more hippie Clues you
think I'm pretend to be a boy and I
happen to be very into peace and love at
eight I'm sorry I thought you were
saying in real life you were hippie your
costume my costume was a big rainbow
like like a fake peace sign necklace and
they go what are you so they're basing
it on your face oh yeah it might have
like big poofy uh hippie yeah hippie
hair but you were a hippie I was a
hippie a male hip also could read
Italian Jewish boy girl sure you'll do
it all baby but at that age that was
that was the age where it's still stung
of course well okay so Joe Pesci who
wanted to murder Kevin Kevin McAllister
for sure like they're
going again and again and again hoping
to get that child alone
such a nightmare because the more you
articulate the darker yeah it just got
worse yeah I've always thought that
movie there was something like a little
because yeah yeah take it to the they're
trying to kill him uh and he's trying to
kill them it's just it's just a lot uh
but we're talking about Italian culture
Goodfellas uh Joe Pesci stabbing two
questions for you tell me about your
father's obsession with Italian culture
that's sort of where we're at and as a
bonus if you can tell me the first movie
you saw that you were like I shouldn't
have seen this oh I could definitely uh
uh I think I think my dad is
there's just a disconnection uh he's not
close with the family his father left uh
started a second family and I think oh
his father
was Italian and I do believe that his
connection to being Italian is the part
of his father he could still love
despite having you know the such
resentment towards his his father
himself no I wish we had a trophy here
because that's some good I've had a lot
of time to think about my father and his
his choices wait a minute
I wonder if my father's father was into
that sort of thing because sometimes
that's the part that you you can it's
it's a river you both swam in you
connect from can I just say everything
comes down to like at its deepest level
mommy or daddy like it's just something
crying out for something we didn't get
from the Giants that raised us and just
just the
we have a tough relationship but like
he's had medical stuff and it's like in
that moment before the surgery it's just
like it's Primal there's there's a
there's a i my father yeah and it's
impossible to yeah it's it's imprinted
it's just a different that's why I think
it's a young man's game to be like [__]
my dad I'm [__] done with him I'm
like
I know I get it enjoy that enjoy that
time but I enjoy comedically I I make a
lot of jokes about my dad dying and me
not really giving a [__] really because
I think that's
because he only speaks Italian yeah
because he lied he lied to me he left me
in Sicily
so I'm like for the rest of my life I'll
talk [__] about you on stage no I think
it's just it's just it just gets to
speak to
I talk about someone I love you only
talk about you only talk about things
that you know you care about in some
capacity for fact and that's the only
way I can talk about him and not feel
ill is by talking about him dying that's
what what is one of the setups you don't
have to do the whole bit uh you know
like uh uh he calls he's hard to heart
surgery he called to go over his will
and testament made me emotional first
time I realized I might not need a
second job like that like those and just
just yeah all sorts of that kind of
stuff yeah but that's not really
that's not really brutal that's just is
there anything that like really gets to
the point of like and that'll be fine
there's that that is that is underneath
that is like I have a joke similar like
my mom calls me on a Monday and that I
talk to my mom on Sunday so when she
breaks regs yes I get scared who died or
Worse she's just calling to chat like
that's my version of that which is which
is a similar callousness sort of thing
or about the darkness of having older
parents but does it ever get more
appointed yes I think uh forgive forgive
the setup but it is factual about my
family my dad and I we used to be close
then he had my little sister 10 years
younger or so he grew closer to her
which is why I'm closer with my mom
because we both know what it's like to
lose my dad's love to a younger woman
that's great and that's to me when when
he he doesn't seem to perform very often
I could bite that joke and there would
be a little give to it because it is
pure gold like there's no other medals
in it so hard in it and it's and that
one's true that one's to me it's like
that's why I'm like oh no that one's
true it really is true yeah yeah yeah
but uh that's I know that's the type of
because my dad doesn't like watch my
comedy much but that's the one that the
next day he called to say I love you
just as much as your little sister which
is which to me is like I touched on
something I said something that yeah
that's more than the death joke because
that's a little more flipping it's a
joke yeah this one is like he had to
call after it
I'm I'm impressed that he called though
my can I tell you uh the the Lithuanian
uh Irish something equivalent
oh God I hate the story real quick I did
this show in Boston I told my parents
not to come I just can't perform with
them in the room the worst the worst I
can't do my I can't do my job my job is
to literally be a person who has been
liberated from those those Macy's day
parade floats that are my my parents in
my psyche I can't be who I need to be
I'm about to go on stage after the story
before so it'll be real quick literally
about to go on stage openers wrapping up
somebody with a headpiece goes your
Dad's here
and I'm like
not only did he come but he came and
came and that I'm Pete's dad and so they
have to call back and I go let him in
but I'm freaking out then I go on stage
I tone down because I was two sketches a
little bit I turned down some of the
jokes about my dad but one of them I was
like I can't it's this great story
about how my dad doesn't know how to use
his phone and there's a part in the joke
where I go give me the [__] phone dad
because I see him mashing the phone and
I go give me the [__] phone I go I
didn't say that I'm terrified of my dad
I went give me the phone papa might I
help you you know
and that was the only thing he said
about the show was he going are you
scared of me Peter and I this is the
next day by the way and I go no Dad it's
just a joke and he goes are you scared
of God Peter
and I'm like let's just use the
transitive property Dad I'm your God
right Peter it's like I frighten you
like God frightened you like like there
was this weird does he know it or is him
it's separate entities
that's ex what you just asked is what I
want to talk about you know what I'm
saying is the hyper awareness of going
like you just asked are you scared of me
I answered there was a pause and my
dad's just thinking and then he goes are
you scared of God and I'm like everyone
knows you're going like he probably is
scared of me it's probably good to be
scared of me this Bible says you're
supposed to be scared like you're scared
of God I must be like God to Peter I
want a Peter scared of God are you
scared of God Peter and I'm like
everyone sees what you're doing but
maybe I mean I don't have religious
parents and I feel like maybe it's it's
frustrating because you talk to you want
to talk to them and you have to deal
with all the metaphors that they might
not even be fully cognizant of but you
are cursed with the the knowing that
they're not talking about God they're
talking about you and him right and my I
wouldn't call my father religious uh
even though I think he would be aware
that there's a a it's in your half it's
the fear God part is in the isn't the
prequel one of the I think I called it
your half and you didn't even bad an eye
I I agree I agree for me I'm like yeah
that's exactly how I think about it
my my daddy had this he had this heart
surgery last year did you say Daddy no
oh my God he said dad he yeah Dad he
because for a second I think you you
were you were searching for that no are
you scared of daddy
are you scared of gaudy I Gotti Gotti
g-o-t-t-i love Italian culture uh-huh
yeah uh like we didn't have religion we
he but my dad he would always tell me if
I was like scared of dying he'd always
be like I know there's some part of me
that's that will survive death when I
was a little kid and then there's that
moment what when you were a little kid I
had I was a very excited I Will Survive
death yeah it was about me too I mean it
was about my own death more than just
trying to comfort you yes oh for sure
yeah he was not like alcohol he's out of
nowhere yes because that that is like my
Dad we could just be eating a meal and
go they'll be applauding me that
survives just
that's nice
but that's that's yeah I don't know man
but when my dad I think it happens like
when he was going over the heart surgery
I realized like oh I'm supposed to tell
him that now
interesting I am now the one who's
supposed to pretend to know of something
to comfort yes but to comfort in a very
specific way to be to be the parent yeah
the parent lies the parent hides their
own uh being unsure of things to comfort
you to comfort yeah yeah it increases
their certainty to give Comfort yes and
now you're supposed to do that but you
didn't as he was being no no I did of
course of course I don't think I
directly said like I know there's some
part of us that but like you know I just
know
if I'm when I'm on my deathbed or before
surgery and someone's trying to comfort
me with like anything religious I'm
gonna be like you're just saying this
you're just saying this because I'm in
this position and I know that and so I
can't even get the good part of it
someone drugged me up so I can I can
just be chill for a second be a normal
just go that's nice my father what
mobster movie is it where someone is
he's like bombed and he's burnt up real
bad and a priest comes up to him and
goes you can repent you can repent my
dad used to love this movie I don't know
what it is because the mobster leans up
to the priest and goes [__] you and dies
and my dad loves that I feel like yeah
because I'm telling you like I can't
speak to my father's uh spiritual
reality I'm just saying like I remember
him I think kind of feeling maybe just
that I mean look I'm spiritual I can
concede that that is an incredibly
badass
thing to do so I I'm not saying my dad
likes it so therefore he's a nihilist or
a material sure I'm saying I'm spiritual
and I can recognize that that there's a
part of me that gets a charge from that
imagine
it's like um there was that story about
the guy who climbed a mountain and he
got uh he fell into crevasse and he
almost died but he doesn't and there's
this it's a documentary I'm forgetting
what it's called but there's a part in
his track he literally tracks just
eating snow which I learned from that
movie you can't eat enough snow to stay
hydrated it's impossible but he's just
trying and I know you have to boil it
you have to boil it down I see it's just
too little water that's fascinating I
didn't know because you and I would just
be trying I would have been trying it
for sure he kept trying because it kept
him a little a little more yeah yeah
he's almost dying he's losing his mind
two two things come to mind one was when
he he got a song stuck in his head after
a certain point there's like a mental
break and he said it was like someone's
playing it out of a stereo at full
volume like he couldn't stop hearing the
song yeah and the second thing and he
really made a point of this and this is
when I was religious I'm not religious
anymore sure but he was like and I
didn't call out to God and that's how I
know I'm actually an atheist and he was
really proud of that and I was like look
at that point I even I believed in a
more classic idea of God and even I was
like respect you know what I mean yeah
isn't that what you're saying like you
don't want to just be a fair weather fan
of God I'm gonna die and now I love you
jeebus I'd be fine to be a fair weather
fan if I believed it but I can't I just
I think some people
have something in their brain where they
can't fully believe it without doubt
sure so so I would love to be a pharaoh
you could that I I dream I did shrooms
finally for the first time in my life
and part of me is like I want to know
what drugs I want to take as I have to
deal with death the death and you think
that's one of them oh this is the first
I've done outside a pot so I'm like you
I'm still exploring I want to do the
Ayahuasca all these things okay I
sometimes get scared because I think the
reason I didn't want to do them is
because I'm like well when I do
Ayahuasca then I'll be religious they're
not real I'll be I'll feel something and
if I do it and I don't then there's
there's there's no longer a mystery for
me I want there to be the the mystery of
oh and I do Ayahuasca there's something
I haven't seen yet so I get scared to do
it because if I don't have that mystical
experience then maybe there is none
okay that's interesting I I think I'm
understanding what you're saying but I
one thing I would offer to that is even
if you have a mystical experience when
you come back you can't talk about it so
you still have to Grapple with mystery
like even if you take Ayahuasca leave
your body I had a friend just this past
week did Ayahuasca and
um I don't think they would mind but it
the Ayahuasca said that it was cleaning
their DNA right and I was like what are
you doing it's like I'm cleaning your
DNA and you're and it used a term that
that they didn't know and they were like
we're doing this it wasn't this I just
for some reason I don't want to use
their story exactly yeah yeah let's say
it was mitochondria it was sure but as I
said we're cleaning your mitochondria
and she didn't know that word then
afterwards she looked it up and she's
like oh it says part of DNA and it was
like what the [__] like so the medicine
yeah she had an ineffable like I would
say like Miracle experience I understand
we could say is it possible that she
read that term and forgot it but it was
like a really really weird yeah term
so yes she could have read it and
forgotten it but it doesn't matter what
the with the things that I've done you
come back and you're still like I'll
show you after I did a drawing of an
experience I had you're still just
painting on Cave walls you know what I
mean meaning did I hear you correctly is
that one of your concerns that you'll
have the mystery no so you'll come back
and be like oh I don't get the feeling
of it I won't have the mystery that that
I'll go like like
oh I go okay you know what I do think
there's something and I'll be reassured
of that once I do ayahuasca
I do Ayahuasca I don't get anything I
just am high zero chance and then I come
zero zero in fact okay I'd put 10 grand
on the table in fact if you did come
back and say I didn't have a spiritual
or mystical experience or an ineffable
experience or a trans-rational
experience yes all I would say was John
Marco your ego couldn't handle what you
experienced and to reframe it said I
didn't have an experience so Terence
McKenna will talk about so Ayahuasca is
is long is like slow release DMT there
are people that smoke DMT and they go it
didn't work and what's happening is
there's so much resistance that
everything in your worldview says what
just happened didn't happen that your
brain will actually like self-delete the
experience and go like it didn't work
but then he says well let's try again
and they go no no no no
but why wouldn't you want to try again
if it didn't work because it did work
but you deleted it in the same way that
we delete a lot of like dramatic or
let's forget about traumatic like a lot
of times you wake up you you hit delete
on your dreams because it was just too
much of a cluster [__] being inside of a
lava lamp and a sandstorm and but it was
traumatic and strange and it was weird
and it was amazing you just deleted it
it doesn't fit in but children I think
don't have as sharp of a delete button
as we do yeah sharp of it you know what
I mean as an effective at a leap so it's
possible you would come back and say I
didn't have an experience but if you did
that it would be an extreme overreaction
of a self-protection mechanism not a
failure of of the medicine it would it
would be something you did to protect I
think I would feel it in that case
shrooms for me I very much like yeah
it was just just uh oh it's always it's
always cliche what's so funny is like I
felt one with the universe cliche it's
like well that's still a great great
feeling to yeah I felt can I bury my yes
and that until we say all profound
truths are entirely cliche yes like
saying like God Is Love by which which
is such a cliche you take mushrooms
you're like oh my God the whole thing is
like written on a backdrop of yes or
sustenance or or or or
that feels like love or feels like a a
cradle or a or I don't like words fail
so you end up saying God is love and
then you're like ah [__] I think I'm a
cliche I went outside of myself like a
Godlike View and it was like I was like
everything's just one organism and it
can get bad and it can get good and it
just keeps going and I I felt not
nihilistic like nothing mattered but
just like it is what it is and it's just
a thing moving and and and uh something
about it was was peaceful
but it was very I felt like I just like
could see the microcosm of humanity yeah
in the world yes and uh that makes
perfect I dug it there's a real
okay these types of conversations uh
your ego will never like it your ego
doesn't like Annihilation your ego
doesn't know that's why that's why I get
scared by the way it's not
all when I I had my very like uh in
college like a classic existential very
much it and it's about Annihilation I I
don't I don't think about I I didn't
have the religion so I don't think about
hell I don't think about it you just
don't want to disappear I just don't
want to disappear but what's interesting
is your mushroom experience when
jean-margo goes away and is one with the
when when you're one with the universe
you're not there
you know what I mean maybe you were
there was a thread that you were like I
am on a drug and I'm having the feeling
of being one with the universe but if
you really go into perfect Oneness all
individuality is lost and All
specialness Is Lost and this is greatly
threatening to us you know what I'm
saying of course so this is like even
I've been thinking a lot about this
lately is even the thought of like going
into a state like that permanently is a
little bit like the end of Minority
Report do you remember Minority Report
but somewhat they put a collar on you
and they lower you into a freezer yes I
remember that but you're in like a
pleasant state but you're like comatose
okay I think some of us are like a
little afraid of merging with God
because your specialness goes like if
you become one with everything that
means there's no two that means there's
no special yes and it's its own type of
annihilation and I think a big part of
our job here on Earth is to recognize
that that's actually not to be feared
it's this weird
play we're putting on for each other of
Separation but like the Oneness isn't to
be you shouldn't be afraid of it yes in
theory
all the things as a kid were uh not a
kid but in college would they be like
you know do you remember before you were
alive it's just that and I was like
that's horrifying I take no comfort in
this at all I don't want to go to before
I was alive I just had a very like
gripping like anxiety in college that I
was like trying to solve and that's how
I became skeptical because I think I
like went down all the Avenues and
looked into all the things and for a
second believed the the the psychic
thing and then read read the amazing
Randy thing and I was like [__] it's
[__] it's [__]
[__] turn the pages with his breath
but then the amazing the random number
generator the the the Stanford
experience what was that it's just like
I know the random number generation sure
it's uh I think it was at Stanford I
forget what it was called but they had
like a department of psychic studies and
this is how the CAA would you know The
Men Who Stare at Goats that movie it's
it's that Gia CIA but yeah I am not uh
but just these big groups of
organizations who actually took this
seriously and the ways that it was
people being Bamboozled people people
wait so the random number generator I
thought it was like whenever there were
like like 911 or a huge earthquake or a
tsami the numbers tended to be like
these similar numbers what it what is
the one here was the idea that a random
number generator should be random but if
you get some psychic in another room
going two two two you're gonna have more
twos than statistically average and then
there's a billion ways to misinterpret
the data and I understand and there's a
confirmation bias of course yeah and I
think it's overwhelming to see how many
adults like who are like anti-religion
but they bought some of this [__] you
know uh uh Elizabeth kuberos uh she's
the seven stages of grief okay she you
know brilliant psychologist that that
thing is a known she got really into a
psychic
who uh would bring back dead husbands
and sleep with them and and then that's
what happened what it was him
it was him what wrapping himself in
cheesecloth which is is the reason is
cheesecloth is because it's easy to
stuff in crevices like a shitload of
cheese gloves in your mouth or your
[__] I guess wait hold on is this a
bit no then back it up just a little bit
psychic Camp psychic camp where where
this primarily widows would come yes and
they would they would do a ceremony
where he'd bring back their husbands
okay so they could have a final uh [__]
them with cheesecloth so what he would
do what these psychics would do is
basically they're doing magic right so
the way that they would do this magic
trick of the spirit reappearing is they
would have translucent cheesecloth and
the reason it's cheesecloth is because
you can get a lot really small put it
somewhere in your body you can hide it
it's a magic trick and so you turn off
the lights
and then he who comes out he comes out
and they they think it's their husband
okay hold on so the illusion the
attempted illusion is a physical yes
translucent looking person comes into
the room and because of confirmation
advice you wanted to be so true you
covered in cheesecloth looks enough like
my dead husband in the dark room and
you're cheesed yeah and I go there he
has the dick that's a hit but she would
put the cheesecloth on herself no no he
he would he's pretending he's a b he's
either the psychic he's saying this
woman was in this camp and defended this
guy I see and and basically he got away
with it for a long time but then I I
think crabs spread around the camp and
they said what are these ghost crabs
where are they coming from like like uh
like on pubic hair
and he was [__] them he was [__]
them and in the cheesecloth in the
cheesecloth so he put it on I'm your
husband let's let's [__] Val would know
I wasn't it wasn't me because every time
we have sex I go what a baby Reno
we haven't had sex in the past 10 years
without me going what a baby Reno that's
if if this [__] didn't know to
say what a baby I shouldn't be sharing
the end is this is this is that when
it's coming no what a baby Arena no it's
not like that it's the corniest because
I feel so safe and she and her clothes
come off and it just comes out and
involuntarily I just go what a baby Reno
but your dad would love it it's Italian
towning mid in the middle at the end no
it's at the beginning oh it's like
you're smooching that's what I mean the
clothes come off and it Bears the
comment so I say what a baby Arena sure
and then now it's kind of become a thing
I didn't mean to take away from the
cheesecloth story no I think maybe
that's how the camp it'll be a better
way for the camp to go down my wife's
like baby what are you doing you haven't
said it say it say it there's a million
okay I know my baby Reno thing is just
kind of a bit but there's a million
there's no one that could have sex with
Valerie in the way that we have sex she
knows you know what I mean yes people's
sex styles are like thumb prints sure so
there's just a psychic covered in
cheesecloth like like like this is a
non-jokey version but if he licked her
ear I'm not an ear licker like if sure
there's a million Amazing Quiz maybe
before in the readings he goes like your
husband says oh he loved it when you did
the thing what was the thing again like
maybe that's pretty he's finding out
he's finding out and and you used to
love it when he would always say what
did he say he's like I'm not gonna say
that this is like he goes I'm not gonna
say that you can bust me I'm not gonna
say babe Reno I remember
you know what I'm done with this psychic
I'm done what a baby right now that's
when he he turns himself in he goes this
is not right what I'm doing you know
what this is not right would you agree
do you have a partner I do and if you if
we're dead and she saw cheesecloth
there's got to be a jean Marco sure like
hey I have an early morning
hilarious also just like the way you
kiss or don't kiss of course yes that's
a sad you're sad you'll believe it and
this woman this psychologist and it
tastes like cheese Club it's exactly
yeah but he's I mean his crabs that's
how bad that and I well the crabs Val
would be like this is him
rampant with crap just forever yeah you
never took care of it you can see it
never did the shampoo no shampoo no poo
uh that is fascinating
I just remember watching the amazing
Randy who I saw on an airplane once
really he was in first the old boyfriend
in coach no and he's old no no no we
talked on the way out and the boyfriend
was like they only had one upgrade he
actually addressed it and I was like I
turned down an upgrade for my girlfriend
I've I've turned down the upgrade
because you didn't want to be alone
because yeah you want to be together
yeah I wanted to do I would I would have
done it if I had a blessing but oh what
did she she made it I know I just know
I know better I feel like John Marco the
move is you can have the sure but she
didn't want to do that why not she wants
to rather be together how how tall is
this woman uh she's five eight yeah she
doesn't belong in first class you know
how they have those things on carnivals
you got to be this tall that's what
first class could be when I see a child
there with the dangle get this [__]
kid in the overhead
I'm 11 feet tall get this [__] let him
go up in the cockpit and get the little
wings what is he doing how you do it
because it's miserable for me and yeah
that's that's that's three more than me
dude nightmare I can't even imagine what
your life is like there's a lot of first
classes that I'm like this is not enough
like for real like somebody puts their
seat back and I'm like this is coach
this is regular people's coach first
there's no first class for me yes
there's no first class seat for Shaq
there's just coach in the front you hear
the entree the giant story in the
documentary
I want to hear the story about me in
first class he well he he was he was too
even for the nice Jets or whatever he
was taking he was too big for the the
toilet for the takeoff that he'd pick it
up and throw he'd do like a paper
airplane do it where are we going
and they bring out a bucket in the
middle and he they pull the first class
curtains hopefully they're better more
reinforced than the ones we see and he
would have to take a [__] in the bucket
not just a [__]
a giant a giant a giant [__] and then
they bring out the rolls of toilet uh
paper towels we're a couple inches away
from that that life thank God he was
rich I don't know what he'd do you can't
just do that same with Shaq sure when I
saw Shaq I I interviewed most of my
questions I don't know if we use them
we're about showers
toilets have you ever taken a bath
like have you ever taken it has this
[__] ever taken like you just
want to get mad on his behalf like yeah
when do you get to Bath
when I when I say in a nice hotel and I
have a tub Petey's in that tub no do you
leave I leave the water running because
the you know the the extra grain the
extra grain up high so it doesn't go too
high if you turn off the water the
height I like it at the drain starts
activating so I got to keep that water
running and keep it oh my God yeah you
put me in we're already at that I want
to be submerged I don't want this
[__] yeah get those knees in there
get the knees in there these are facts
okay so your dad loved the Godfather and
oh we're talking about the Randy we just
went on an airplane
I I'm with that stuff but there's a lot
of I'm not even like
let's just say this the Cornerstone of
my spiritual reality is not psychic
phenomena sure I don't really care and I
actually I'm gonna put this to you when
a piece of the mystery the amazing Randy
points out a part of the mystery that
isn't factually true I'm just I just
think it's adorable that a piece of life
is going like this piece of Life can't
read my mind do you understand it would
be like it would be like looking in a a
snow globe and in a snow globe there's a
there's a city of amazing sea horses and
they're all wearing sunglasses and
they're all vaping it's the most
incredible thing you've ever seen and in
the snow globe filled with millions of
seahorses some of the seahorses are
going this seahorse says he can read my
mind but he's full of [__] but from my
perspective I'm like you're both
[__] magical vaping sunglass
seahorses that's incredible like what
the how the [__] did you get to be do
you understand like horse when a piece
of the mystery analyzes the mystery and
goes this isn't mysterious I go
[__] you are the mystery you're
looking in a telescope and using the
phenomenon the infinite mystery of
awareness to look at a planet and go
like I know where that planet will be in
three months or you build a bridge or
you make a vaccine you do a lot of
incredible things but you're still the
the observing principle of this
experiment is on understood and and is
under and I feel that sometimes I feel I
want to one of your bits that I always
love is just that it doesn't make any
sense I mean that's because that's the
closest I would get to whatever I would
say I am I mean I'm very skeptical I
would call myself a borderline atheist
but but that is what I try to hold on to
it doesn't make any sense you're
observing this why is this right it's
big yeah but I said I see that scam
stuff and I I I'm not able to see it as
positively if I go [__] I get I get
frustrated at the people being taken
being taken advantage of and I feel this
way about all astrology where it's like
it's cliche at a certain point to like
be like astrology is not but it's also
it's not it's not real
it's not real and you hear about it I
don't know if you've ever gone to a good
astrologist man I dated a girl whose
mother was an astrologist and she gave
her a sealed envelope
she gave when she dated her father she
gave her father a sealed envelope when
they started dating and when their
daughter was born she said open the
envelope and it had her uh daughter's
birth date on it it was just based on
the chart and I know I know what you're
gonna say she faked she swapped the
envelope or whatever and that could be
but I I would say there's about five
billion people in India that firmly
disagree with you and we have to concede
that our culture just doesn't value it
or look into it
I don't know I don't know I think it's
it's uh to say that the planet affected
your thing is me as as maybe as that
affected by the trajectory it does I
know but I don't know but I don't know
how yeah but I don't know how right and
for me to articulate how in any way
shape or form is a projection of my own
hubris yeah yeah yeah and there's a
little pride to it like it's it's the I
know what's going on here that you that
you bump against yes by the way I'm also
not a huge astrology person I've just
had certain experiences where they're
like you know I had an astrologer to
tell me this is when you got divorced
and it was when I got divorced stuff
like that I just think she was a huge
crashing fan and she did the timeline
I just think
we especially on like like the the
liberalist side when we talk about the
vaccine and stuff where people are like
please let's be more scientific as a
country and if you allow too much room
to not go wait a second I think this is
[__] then the line of what is is
truthful becomes blurred and then when
you need people to take science
seriously like when there's a pandemic I
understand you've created a society that
takes truth from some wild places can I
just to agree with you because I do it
sounds like we're disagreeing
um I think what we're running into is I
have a little bit less
um I'm less charged in like going boo
which is fine you're not even saying boo
you're just saying like let's let's use
reason I'm totally with you
um what was I just gonna say the vaccine
Truth uh uh uh uh being telling people
like oh yes here's where I'll agree with
you
when religion astrology
psychic phenomena any of this becomes
certainty worship or any sort of
planting the flag of certainty if any
religion or tradition doesn't have the
humility by the way all of them have
humility baked into them if you look for
it to say this is how we choose to
interpret the UN understandable or the
trans-rational or the Transcendent like
these are our symbols these are symbols
of symbols like words are symbols of
symbols but this is as close as we can
get because we want to experience and
participate with the unknowable because
we can't know it but we can become it or
be it or merge with it or play with it
or like your mushroom thing sort of
commune with it uh if that becomes
certainty and we know what the future is
going to be and I know what happens to
you when you die and I know what happens
to me when I enter one of these people
the certainty worship is not what I'm
about and it sounds like you're railing
against allowing everybody in because
then it dilutes the things that we can
be certain about like mathematics yeah
or graph with the things that are
unknown I just hear the you know you you
hear the oh well I'm a Leo I'm not going
to get along with the blah blah blah and
you're like that doesn't that's not
that's not real and that's not real and
or you could say it's real because the
chances that you won't get along with
somebody are so high of course right
it's like saying this Stone predicts
you'll get divorced or not and you could
flip a coin and know if people are gonna
get divorced tonight oh you're a Leo I
knew it
and then I'm like what does that mean
you're obstinate your stubborn you're a
jackass it's it's never it's never like
the brave because I always say I'm like
I'm not brave I'm not brave at all yeah
oh Leos are brave that's a lion it's
it's but I put it like if people ask you
it all the time I read about some some I
want to be this person he was on some
talk show I think it was a scientist and
some actor said what's your sign and he
said I would not uh uh undignify your
Audience by uh pretending like I
believed in that he wasn't trying to he
was a little nicer yeah he wasn't saying
shut the [__] up he was that guy but he
was respect for your audience to
participate in that and that's what I
think I think especially with astrology
people really like want you to
participate in a way that if I came at
them with any kind of religious thing
yeah they'd go like don't push this on
me and they do it casually they do it in
business and work meetings yeah yeah no
you're right it's funny you're right
it is sort of like a right V happy sort
of situation because what I'm thinking
right now and again just so you know
you're not who you're talking to I don't
really care I do know that the world is
overwhelming and it's scary yes and when
I see people say I'm a Red Sox fan over
here and these people say I'm a Libra
over here I go same [__] thing man
and there's certain Trends and certain
patterns to everything yeah and the
words and the rituals and the systems
that we use to try and understand this
very strange hallucination we're all
sharing in
uh I can have compassion for that you
can have compassion but then you look at
the cases where it goes awry you you
look at the the movements where it
becomes certainty that uh at least
suicide where like where I think my
cynical view of it is I just go it all
has the capacity for Badness so figure
out a sports thing figure out a
community thing figure out a garden yeah
before you do yeah this which is
entirely yeah fabricated and pushed
forward by whoever writes the astrology
section in The Huffington Post which I
don't know if it still is but used to be
in the women's voices section which
doesn't make any [__] sense right I
mean it does but it doesn't right it's
uh right
I I you I'm not a jerk about it like
randomly to people but I do feel I think
astrology is frustrating because I find
myself in in circumstance where I don't
want to answer the question what's my
sign yeah because I really am like you
might as well make a stop you're trying
to stop stop and then they'll go classic
Leo
thankfully oh that they do that all the
time oh you know this project
classically oh
such a Leo trade who are you hanging out
with just like astrology
I gotta stop going to this astrology
Club it's my fault I'm putting myself in
the scenario I want to come back to this
because I think you did this is very
interesting let's just go to the we have
a couple mid-roll that year a podcaster
I'm gonna do the mid-rolls we'll be back
in two minutes and I I want to tell you
what I loved about what you just said
and we'll go a little bit deeper and
then man this I'm already loving this
we'll be right back
this show is brought To Us by our
friends at Sunday's food for dogs my dog
Brody absolutely absolutely loves
Sundaes it's a healthy dog food that is
actually easy to store and serve we've
tried a lot of different good high-end
nice Healthy dog foods for Brody and
oftentimes that just means there's tons
and tons of plastic containers in our
refrigerator taking up all of the space
Sundays is not like that it's like
having a box of cereal in your pantry
but it is filled with Incredible air
dried dog food made from a short list of
human grade ingredients that you can
pour and your dog devours seriously when
we pull this out no joke Brody runs like
a dog food commercial and devours this
food and it is incredible let's be
honest for his poops I mean that's a big
part of why you want to give your dog
premium good stuff obviously for his
health and also for what you have to
pick up when you're walking them and
Sundays ticks both of the those boxes
Sunday's was co-founded by Dr Tori of
practicing veterinarian it contains 90
percent meat 10 vegetables and zero
percent synthetic nutrients besides USDA
beef and all natural chicken you'll find
digestive AIDS like pumpkin and ginger
plus disease fighting antioxidants dog
parents report noticeable Health
improvements in their pups including
softer fur fresher breath better poops
like I mentioned and more energy and I
love how happy it makes Brody and I
really love how easy it is to make Brody
that happy unlike other fresh dog food
Sunday is Sundays is zero prep zero mess
and zero stress like I said it's shelf
stable which makes it super easy to feed
your pup top quality food and every
order ships right to your door so you'll
never worry about running out of dry out
of dog food again Sundays cost 40 less
than other Healthy dog food brands
because Sundays doesn't waste money
shipping Frozen packages and and there's
also a lot of less there's so much less
waste instead they spend on what matters
sourcing the best all-natural
ingredients for your pup so we've worked
out a special deal for weirdos our dog
loving weirdos get 35 off your first
order of Sundays go to Sundays for
dogs.com weird or use code weird at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash weird and upgrade your pup to
Sundays and feel good about the food you
feed your dog speaking of things I swear
by I'm I was just feeling a little bit
behind myself today and I just took some
of my next Evo Naturals next Evo is a
huge Game Changer in my life a huge
secret weapon against stress in my life
and their stress CBD complex gummies are
incredible and a new year is a fresh
opportunity to achieve your full
potential but you can't be your best if
you are stressed so get ahead of stress
this year by experiencing the full
potential of CBD with next Evo Naturals
next Evo Naturals is the most clinically
studied CBD brand and their smart sword
technology can help you get a better
start to the year with their products
like the stress CBD complex why this one
instead of the millions and millions it
seems other CBD companies because of
that smart sword technology
if you've tried CBD before and it didn't
do anything for you I implore you to
give next Evo a try their smart sword
CBD has a patented whole plant
ashwagandha which is clinically proven
to reduce stress by up to 70 and improve
concentration by 50 and also it's proven
for 30 times better absorption in the
first 30 minutes so the number one
complaint I hear about CBD is people
don't know how much to take and they
don't know if they notice it with this
you can dial in the dose perfectly
because it's absorbed 30 times better
and it's going to get into your blood
and into your mood in 30 minutes so you
get it fast and you get it all of it is
getting into you it's not getting wasted
it's not just passing through your
system so don't just use any CBD brand
most CBD products on the market only
have two to ten percent absorption so at
least 90 percent is actually wasted next
Evo is different delivers four times
better overall CBD absorption and has
been proven in multiple clinical trials
so I absolutely swear by it if you've
been on the fence or you tried some
other brands before and were
disappointed give it another shot I
swear the stress complex gummies are
incredible they also make these pills
which are great I sometimes take those
at Bed make CBD a part of reaching your
full potential of next Evo Naturals go
to nextevo.com podcast and use promo
code weird to get 20 off your first
order of 40 or more that's 20 off 40 or
more at n e x t e v o.com slash podcast
and use promo code weird and as I always
say they'll be showing your support of
the show last but not least this show is
sponsored by betterhelp when you're at
your best you can do great things we
talk a lot about the benefits of talk
therapy on this show I am a huge
believer Val is a huge believer
is greater than the sum of its parts
talking to a trained professional seems
like just words in a room right but it
changes your life it's changed my life
it's changed Val's life it's changed so
many of my friends life and we're so
happy to be sponsored by better help
sometimes in life you get bogged down
you can feel overwhelmed or like you're
not showing up in the way that you want
to working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you feel
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you so if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try better help is an
incredible option it's convenient it's
flexible it's affordable and it's
entirely online I used to drive 90
minutes to see Dr Gary pen my therapist
it was a haul and if I knew about better
help absolutely game change the whole
system you go online it's discreet it's
easy you do it from the comfort of your
home it's easy to swap therapists it's
easy to find therapists there's no shame
Factor there's no discomfort and there
there's no inconvenience just fill out a
brief questionnaire and get matched with
a licensed therapist and you like I said
you can switch at any time for no
additional charge because dialing it in
just right and finding that perfect
person for you can sometimes take a try
or two but once you do you know you're
there and you'll start feeling those
benefits and showing up for yourself so
much more in your life which is
incredible so if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can absolutely
get you there for me it helped me carry
through a terrible breakup and was a
very integral time in my life where I
was at a Crossroads and I had to make a
lot of choices and having a therapist to
talk to made all of the difference so
visit
betterhelp.com weirdo today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
betterhelp.com
weirdo for 10 off your first month and
show your support of this show all right
everybody let's enjoy the second half of
jean-marcos oracy get into it
we're right back I'm Mark Norman all of
a sudden I'm back that's good
um it wasn't good
yeah it's okay it was okay you knew what
I was doing I like Mark Norm was one of
those him and like Melanie I can't
listen to because I just imitated them
murder you reminded me no you reminded
me of Melanie when you went there was
something you said it's bad it's it's in
me Jeff and Melanie are both in me Jeff
Jeff Goldblum I've done an impression
for him like for multiple things Jeff
Goldwell and yeah
I thought you said you haven't met him
no I haven't met I've done Impressions
oh I think he said for him oh no no of
him if I tell you when I met him please
because you're gonna love it oh yeah
finish your thing though uh but it's
those two are baked in my mind and I
can't
sun is Melanie the musicality feels like
well that's what comedy is like it's
it's almost it's it's no no like he
hears it he hears what we're trying to
hear yeah more clearly so I'm not saying
repum but I don't think you are ripping
him but I'm saying saying you have a
little Melanie in you is like a cake
being like I've got some yeast sure
because what he is is a very pure
example of what we're all doing does
that make sense yes did people ever call
you because I just get so many I get so
many comments on the YouTube of Dollar
Store John Mulaney Dollar Store Dollar
Store John Mulaney and it's it's wow do
you ever get a dog do you ever get a
back in the day they were like oh you're
just a you're just a poor man's oh no
never because when I was starting comedy
it was like a fringe activity I'm sure
I'm joking but no that's hurtful that
you're a dollar oh it's fine oh
my I can't listen to him is Brian Regan
yeah yeah
that's that's a real thing but keep I
mean I know I I'm listening I'm not it's
too late sometimes at a certain point
you do a comedy long enough you're like
I might evolve but this is what I am
dude I dude it's already on my mind if I
watch Burr I'll be a little bit more
Burr if I follow Santino I'll be a
little bit more Santino in fact coming
out of the quarantine I was like
I've told the story before but like to
to him
but sometimes I forget what comedy is
and you need these avatars you need your
melanies you need your Burrs and and
santinos these guys that are like
fearless and you're like I'm not just
saying this when I watched your set I
was like oh yeah such a Leo going up
there brave but you did like I I one of
the greatest things I'm realizing that
this is great that I mean this because
in my life I've I have folders on my
phone who who my friends are I have to
write it down sure and I also have a
folder on my phone called things I
actually like because I forget I lose my
way in the forest and and I do love
comedy but one of the things when I say
that what do I mean when I watch someone
do like the set you did in Montreal
or when I watch Burr tear up a small
room and just really
remember George Burns smoke cigars and
cigar he said the cigar was the ultimate
comedy accessory because it like it's
imposing yes the smell that fills the
room there's something
I that's not appropriate for all
situations but the fearlessness that you
in Montreal or or these guys that
said I watched Santino do where he just
went up and
did it yeah he didn't like apologize it
was like athletic I do get inspired by
that like it's not fake I actually get
like moved that someone can be so
honest about their feelings and their
truth I know this sounds kind of like
canned but I get like
like it's not emotional it's inspired I
go like what sometimes okay so one of my
core negative beliefs is that I'm too
much like sure I I know that feeling
right I know like I'm too much people
secretly hate everything I'm about so I
had I had had very little sleep uh
because I was watching Lilo alone for
three days then I went to coffee and she
just she was rocking me like just I was
getting rocked by this child and yeah
and you just I don't mean you I just
nobody can understand what it's like how
old no she's four and she's the love of
my life I love her more than anything
but she doesn't sleep great and when
she's awake you're with her and you just
it's like having another
more important you running around so
there's just constant and there's a lot
of okay and then I finally get her to
school on Monday because I was with her
over this weekend
and I'm sitting there and I'm just in
like uh zero like like the realist me
because I'm grumpy and I'm on little
sleeves and I'm just exhausted and
somebody asked me about my dog and
everybody knows that listens to this
podcast I have mixed feelings about my
dog and my dog was really bothering me
because my what I said was my dog is my
mom my mom is just like it can be very
like bottomless yeah like there's It's
never enough so when I say I don't like
my dog has nothing to do with my dog in
fact my dog is a good boy I treat him
very well I have to say that up top at
June very well very loving he's in a
loving situation but sometimes when I
look at him and he's just staring me
with those black eyes I just feel my
mother goes like for your dad is God for
your mama yeah
and one's backwards dog god
so anyway I'm ranting about this and
then at the end of the I'm driving home
and I'm like with like five friends at
this coffee place and I'm like what the
[__] am I doing why am I venting about
my dog nobody wants to hear about how
you how you have like a complicated
relationship with your dog people hate
that and then I go when I see you or
like I'm saying these great sets sharing
their vulnerability in a powerful not an
imposing or dickish way but like in an
Unapologetic this is my Neurosis I love
it that's how I comfort myself meaning
if you had been ranting about your dog
and being like my dog is my mother she's
always staring me like why do people
think it's love he just wants my [__]
food he's just following me for my
[__] food he's a wolf yeah if you
were doing that I would love it a
hundred percent and that's how I comfort
myself when I'm too much does that make
sense it's like what I love about comedy
yeah I mean that's why I I you know I
didn't start it I was I was an actor and
theater person I think just I mean other
than not a lot of success but I think
there's ultimately was like oh I want to
go into myself I do yes it's and show it
it's how I it's it's I can't even do
like I can't even write outside myself
you know they say you know it's it's
that some people would never write a
show with where they're the main
character of it yeah and it's hard for
me to conceive of doing anything else
yeah yeah now I can't it's it's
I I think it's like I think that's
always been in me when I was a kid I I
would like I would I would hand raising
for those of you listening not watching
I'm raising my hand couldn't relate more
keep going when both my parents house I
was going back they got divorced when I
was young but we would put on music we
would dance in the living room
and I remember at a young age I said we
have people need to people need to
witness this I didn't say it like that
but I said we need to figure out a way
to get our living room on a stage so
people the the idea that something was
given more value and worth by it also
being witnessed and me being the thing
that needed was there from the beginning
buddy cut to me and my friend Miguel my
best friend in uh whatever second grade
we built a stage my idea in the backyard
with wood and we stood on it I didn't
have any talents so I just stood out I
got it from Looney Tunes or something
would just go wax packs ooh wax packs I
don't even know what the song means I
went ooh daddy oh where you gonna go on
the radio just in the back picture two
kids in the woods yeah just sing in wax
packs imagine if you walked by the two
wax bit wax packs boys couldn't agree
more and I used to think I was on a
reality show this is before reality
shows that's why I loved being religious
because I thought angels are God were
watching me so I would monologue into
the mirror and I'd say welcome to the
peach show dad's having a weird dinner
like I just it's like psychosis or you
know it's it's it's not
stable it's instable it's it's instable
and that's what we do for a living but
I'm happy to hear that you were trying
to get the Avett Brothers also I
remember
um Scott Avett was talking about like
that play in their house music yeah and
he thought that the way it would work is
one day somebody would walk by pop their
head in the window and say I'm from
Hollywood you guys have to come with us
that's what he thought and that's also
part of it not only do you think what
you're doing deserves to be seen but
you're also like and someone's gonna
come and find this and and claim it yeah
I think
it was as soon as I feel a stand-up
comedy it sometimes feels like I had
that urge but I didn't have any of the
regular things we view as talent to
deserve being on stage yeah I feel it
insecurity because I failed at other
things that got me two stand-up comments
which I love right but I also feel like
I was a failed singer I feel like I was
a failed actor and that's how I got here
but but there's something it's it's more
it's less about the the talent it's just
like when I was a kid we had a Yamaha
and I remember I called I couldn't play
piano my dad just had for some reason
yeah it was a hobby how have I never put
together yamaka and Yamaha
it'd be a strange bit for you to do I
think
I would feel the Jews would say leave
that for us please
get behind the Yamaha
I somebody he must have Adam Sandler
must have used the rhyme at some point
there's no way you like are trying to
run yeah like Dora the Explorer lights
the menorah I think about this all the
time is Dora the Explorer Jewish could
she be for the song quit it you know
okay
and I was just playing and I couldn't
play but I like I did the spookies I did
like a spooky sound and I said Dad come
look at this and who knows what the [__]
I did but in my mind I was telling a
story banging on the keys and my dad was
like I don't what what was what if what
am I supposed to he didn't know what to
do with it yeah yeah yeah and it's like
I didn't have talent I wish I could have
played the piano but I still there's
like I'm like you need to see whatever
it is I'm feeling right now for the
feeling to be complete to me like you
had the best seat in the house
just like I I was making something and
and he didn't know what right and I
think I think part of it is like can you
be worthy of being witnessed can you be
worthy of people's time because yes okay
if people are gonna look you you better
give them something was that memory then
like oh before I can invite my father
over I better learn how to play I just
think it's no it's it's more like oh my
dad doesn't get it I'm at the moment
this is before I like had the
self-awareness I was like my dad doesn't
get it I'm a genius
something in me is something in me
tapped into the Divine and my dumb
[__] father all he hears is noise
this is uh this is right out of my brain
right here when I get stoned I'm
convinced I can play the piano
I'm very I think I'm very good I would
record it and play it and be like it's
pretty good for a guy who can't play the
piano really sounds pretty good yeah
yeah same same sort of thing so and some
composers be like the notes don't make
any sense yet it's beautiful yeah
exactly yeah like it takes a genius to
recognize this genius yeah yeah like a
regular person would be like this is
madness you'd be like but wait like I
always wanted like an anthropologist to
listen to something like you playing the
piano and be like what he's doing he's
calling to a dentist that's true you
know like like something beautiful is
happening yeah because that's what I
meant by like you're in the best seat in
the house like if you if they are father
whoever knew what it feels like to get
in that flow where you're kind of
lighting up with potential like I'm
making notes but you're like being hyper
present and playful and yeah the feeling
of yes yesing your impulses to play
whatever notes like that is what was
happening and it was beautiful yeah and
unfortunately we live in a world where
we're like but I what what are hooks
what is rhythm what is sure a pre-chorus
what's repeating the chorus again at the
end it's just inviting other people in
so like regular folks can go like I see
why this is good you know what I mean
and I can't blame them for not
understanding because they're not
artists yeah they're not feeling it my I
was at my mom I was I was in bed I was
like just wrapping in my tummy and I was
like 12 or whatever and like I got
really into it yeah I like thought I was
making it simply and my stepfather at
three in the morning because everyone
was like what the [__] is going on in
here because to him he's like what the f
what are you doing you are killing me
you woke me up for what is this we are
so similar I have a very vivid memory
I'm laying in bed I didn't recognize
what it was now I have words for it I'll
tell Valerie I'm I'm I'm have I'm manic
I'm not a manic depressive but I get lit
up of course and I'm infinite potential
and the reason I have to tell Val is is
it's like you're not allowed talking to
me to tell your friends that you can
make a TV show for them because in that
state I can see a pilot for everyone and
I'm actually gonna say it'd be good like
it's not like just Insanity you know yes
and we're time travel it would be like a
good like oh I get it and this and this
but I have to go sure come up with an
idea for John Marco but don't pitch it
until you've come down from this you
know what I'm saying yes so when I was
manic as a child I didn't know what it
was I just thought I was having this
intense surge of creative will and
positivity yeah I got out of bed like
you with your and I I thought this felt
like genius to me too I was like if I
lay my head upside down my hair will
fall to the floor and then if I hair
spray it it'll stay like that but this
is like 11 o'clock at night but I
couldn't get it out of my mind like yeah
like something I had to create and I
went in the bathtub and I started
spraying with hairspray and my mom came
out and like your was it your dad uh
that was my step tab your step dab worse
even worse even worse infinitely worse
yeah yeah more than a step worse yes my
mom was did not find it amusing at all
and I do think it's just because that
was the 80s if Leela did that I would be
like this is a memory like I would take
a a photo but isn't that I also was like
but what did my mom have to do the next
day like why sure why couldn't it have
just been fun do you think
you would have been better off if if she
had if she said wow no cool no because
just like your dad saying your piano
sucks and my mom's saying this is this
is inappropriate get back in bed you nut
job that with that combo of love and
withholding love is what I think addicts
us to
bad sets good sets bad sets good like
the the strange like I I think it's like
make no mistake we don't actually want
to kill every set we want we want the
speed ball we want the downer yeah we
want the upper and the bad set informs
the good set and the and the nice run of
good sets and then like a weird set in
the background I think it would be tough
to be like a self-aware parent because I
think I would be very much like I want
them to feel good I'm proud of them for
everything yeah and like where's
where's you need something else where
where where's son as a parent you do
have to be critical of your child or you
do have to be like I I don't know yeah
because I would be the parent I go to my
son playing the piano go oh my God and
and then oh he's like I'm a genius for
real and then he goes on stage and does
it and gets booed by the whole world
well that's that's
I think you just solved your own problem
though like it's gonna happen yes it
doesn't have to be you we're back to
what we said at the beginning like these
archetypes mother father are so huge so
Leela just yesterday morning knows a
song that's the days of the week and it
goes like Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday and then again
there's Sunday so and she was counting
on her fingers but she counted eight and
she went there's this many days in the
week and Val was like she valve told me
the story because she felt bad she was
like oh sweetie actually there's seven
days in the week and Leela just went
like
so like it's gonna happen what I'm
saying is this belief that like we have
to like damage our children to make them
interesting or to toughen them up it
happens gently yes it doesn't like you
can't knock because you and I were the
types of kids and I'll put this back to
you you thought you're a genius I've
told the story many times it's not even
a story it's this long it's almost over
I'm in the back seat and I'm listening
to my brother and father talking I'm
like I was noticing that there's a
rhythm you know when you're a kid you
just talk yeah and then grown-ups I'm
like oh they're like
but I saw it like sheet music I'm still
convinced that I was having like an
epiphany and an epiphany that was
smarter than my years I had never heard
people talk about things like that and I
was like and I explained it to them I
waited for my turn in the music and I
was like
and my dad didn't say anything and my
brother was like yeah people know that
and I was just like that was me going
like well we'll see who's laughing when
I'm a famous comedian yes like yeah like
literally that was pulling the bow back
on me being like okay but that's the
whole Drive is we have those feelings
and then we go like what do I have to do
to make someone else bring them in on
this feeling that's right yeah and
that's what back to what we were saying
when Radiohead Radiohead put out that
um there was a certain record all I
remember was the song butcher was on it
I can't remember the name of it but it
was after in rainbows so they put out in
rainbows and everybody was like this is
the greatest Radiohead record of all
time and then like the next one was like
very for them sure I think that's what
makes us so upset is that we know
they're Geniuses they just didn't make
enough effort to bring us into it yeah
because Radiohead could probably like I
feel like Tom York could just hear like
a
and it'd be like oh yeah this is [__]
brilliant because he's a genius yeah we
need your Genius to be changed and
dressed up a little bit so we can get a
little taste of what it feels like to be
you does that make sense yes and when
you don't we go you didn't extend us
enough rope to join sure climb up I'm
mixing metaphors but I can't get into
your Tower Rapunzel it's not even rope
sure of course I mean that's what I mean
it that's why some comedians
get rich and it's so disappointing
because it feels like they no longer can
extend that to you the regular human
being oh because all their bits are
about private jets or or just their
whole attitude towards it's just
different they live in a different world
they're breathing different air yeah and
there's just something in there that's
not not the same completely agree I
thought you're also going to say when
comedians tell a joke that doesn't make
sense
they're you're it's the same thing they
didn't they didn't extend enough rope to
bring I'm sure sure and Rory Rory
Scoville one of my favorites he's like
me I was watching him at my Largo show
uh this past month and he did this bit
and he said something kind of out of
nowhere and then he did what I would do
I'm a real like I don't know why you
didn't laugh at that guy and he said
like I don't know why you didn't laugh
at that and I'm sitting in the wings and
I'm like oh my God it's because he
didn't say
she said like there was something
missing and I'm like that's what I do I
get so caught up in the Mania or the the
thrill of finding pure creativity in my
brain and letting it spin like a
pinwheel that sometimes I forget to say
and then my dad goes yes so now I'm just
a lunatic on stage going like Are You
Afraid Of God then they go why aren't
you laughing and I'm like because
lunatic like you're scribbling in the
notebook from Seven you're Kevin Spacey
you're like you're insane that's but
that's why it's so hard to get like
really good feedback on stand up you got
to have like your friends who because
sometimes you just can't tell yeah you
can't tell what you have failed to
communicate when someone points it out
and you go oh when I said him they
didn't know who I was talking about yeah
but in your head you're like of course
it's this that's what I mean that's why
I think we have the best seat in the
house like you with the piano yeah it's
like if you know everything I know I can
picture the people I'm talking about
they they get a description and they
cast it their own ways yeah I got the
original whatever weird person and I was
running into at the airport or whatever
and that's why hold on some jokes I've
held on to for six years because I'm
like no it's there there's it's it's
I'll figure it out but I know yeah I
know there's something there yeah well
when you not that you haven't but like
when you really establish yourself and
have like multiple specials that's when
those bits come back because then the
audience completely gets you yes and
that's when I like I have to often check
myself before I wreck myself because I
perform a lot at Largo that audience
knows me pretty well and I feel like I
can go from a to F and then you go to a
regular place and you're like no a to c
is is pushing it here you have to yeah
like you were saying in the midwest you
have to go like I'm Jewish that means of
course you know like you have to explain
I have to explain my perspective as well
but at a certain point you can bring
those bits back I'm completely I just
think it's so you know I don't have uh
you all go to a show on the road it'd be
a couple fans there but like I do think
a lot about like how do you stay good
when the people who see you perform know
all the context and know you so deeply
and it's like I have those experience
sometimes where I have a couple shows
where it's like people come to see me
yeah little things and you know they
know my girlfriend's name yeah they know
they know all this background this is
bad for you no because I don't I no
longer it's like it's like I'm trying to
build a house that can stand anywhere I
could perform it anywhere yeah but then
in that moment I I I have a disjointed
they know stuff they have context that I
haven't not figured out how to convey to
a stranger and so as you become more
famous as you have more fans it seems to
be really hard to maintain working out
really brutally good material that could
work with people who have no idea who
you are
yeah it's interesting and I think you
would do well to never stop building the
house from the ground up sure what I do
is I just invite people into my house
now you know what I mean yeah but when I
watch your material one of the things
that I'm so impressed by it and a lot of
the younger people is I'm seeing the
house they build the house yeah I I and
I'm not even saying this is a bad thing
Bill Burr is letting you in the house
he's not he's not going like I'm Bell
I'm kind of curmudgity yeah and mullaney
doesn't go like that says my deal he
just goes out forget it like you know
when he had the dog and his relationship
all that stuff like that everybody knew
that going in and wanted to hear him
talk about it but I wonder
I wonder if you do lose something if
you're not trying to make the thing that
can be dropped into a like I wonder if
I'm soft because like if I go to a show
and someone brings a friend they're like
they didn't know who you were I'm like
that's so weird whereas the first 10
years 12 to 15 years of my career 100 of
every crowd didn't know who I was of
course and that's how you get strong
yeah so I wonder if it's lazy or if it's
just kind of like
something that you earn I I like to
think it's something that I've earned
yeah yeah I mean there's there's an
argument made you you know you do you
get a certain benefit of the doubt as
you've proven yourself over the years
and that lets you explore you know yeah
yeah
like I can think of clubs uh I I worked
at uh I still do so once a while lol in
New York like the real like Times Square
yeah yeah yeah it used to be ha yeah
[__] Club but they added a letter yeah
it's a rough Place rough but I was I did
every check spot there for like a year
in the beginning and it was it was
useful but like if if I try to do you
did every check spot that's what they
offered you yeah it was it was because
unpaid yeah excited like but it's in New
York these days it's the only way I
could have done four spots a night six
on the weekends yeah yeah but it was
sometimes you just need to be on stage
with a microphone even if it's a
nightmare that's that was for me the
Boston but yeah keep going but it's
still it's but I'm sure back then I
could have never done something as
profound as uh none of this makes sense
that audience would have been like what
is going and then so you so you don't
you the other argument is that when you
do have people who have some context you
can build yeah a much more precious
thing yeah yeah
I'm gonna I wonder if you'll think this
is as fun as I think you're gonna think
it is okay the bit that doesn't make any
sense was
what I would call a special bit meaning
for a special meaning if I'm doing an
hour even for my fans I wouldn't always
do that doesn't make any [__] sense
by the way I had no idea that would
become the the viral bit or whatever
yeah because often it didn't really work
really so then you're doing a special
and the crowd is extra Juiced yeah yeah
and you do it kind of towards the
beginning then you can make it work I
have a set list right now I'm working
out this new hour I'm going to film it
uh there's two bits on it that I will
not do when I'm just working a regular
room because they're too intimate
they're better with a camera close to
your face they're based on an Expression
they they involve like literally 20
seconds of silence and I'm like I can't
do that like I could but it's too risky
sure and I I just want to murder but for
the film set those are the bits that
like you do doesn't make any sense even
though you wouldn't do doesn't make any
sense doing just a regular theater or
whatever you do it on the special and
then everybody loves it it's
it's uh I I wonder if you does that make
no oh it makes total sense it's it's
very interesting I think it's like it's
too delicate I'm saving for the TV
tapering I just think there's like some
like older Comics have done it for a
long time where sometimes they're doing
that and they're still making great work
and then there's some where it's like oh
no this actually does need it's not as
sharp as you as as you think you're
getting way too much from from the
silent and the and I think it must be
hard to navigate this is we I'm
constantly in spaces where no one knows
who I am and I think like if I'm not
it's just got to be hard to hold I I
don't know how Chris Rock goes anywhere
and he walks in and everyone yeah knows
who he is yeah and they're excited to
see him even if they're not a fan
they're just like oh my God I get to
tell my family so Chris Rock how do you
do how do you how do you develop
anything
in an authentic way yeah no I I
completely understand it's interesting
it's interesting have you ever seen a
ghost
what if you were like you had
yeah a reverse on all this like there's
one exception hate astrology but
I've been haunted would you like to be
haunted as a skeptic because I can
arrange it I'm just kidding please I
think of uh would you like it Stephen
King had some quote where he said all
horror movies are all ghost movies
are optimistic because it implies
there's life after death right so he was
saying like even if it's like a [__]
monster it's like well at least you get
to be a [__] monster when I die
hey that's something that's not nice I
like lumbering in a group sure
some good meals
look pretty good let's be honest of all
the organs brain looks most delicious oh
really which organ are you gonna eat
mussels aren't organs we're eating an
organ okay okay I feel like a liver
feels closer to like steak even Hannibal
did he eat brains in the movie he had
liver and a nice Chianti
uh what about have you ever almost died
um I
so lame I I couldn't ride a bike so so
okay okay okay
and uh I'm having trouble with the bike
it is so I had like I would describe it
as like a chariot so like the front
wheel of a bike connected to like two
skateboards so no balance required yeah
and my dad I was going down a hill and
my dad was like don't hit the brakes
don't hit the brakes this time and I
wasn't wearing a helmet and so I had to
bring you in because this is so
traumatic yeah uh and I would start
going really fast really fast and there
was like a dip at the end over a little
who knows but slinging me was like
this you gotta step off and I like like
cold cold spot just as a move and just
took a step off
and you know smacked broken arm didn't
hit my head if I had I do think dead
dead wow and I I think it was better
than the option at the bottom of the
hill and I think my brain like really
quickly made a cold hard calculated
reservation because in my mind I could
see being like too scared to step off
the thing so you just keep going you
don't make a decision yeah but something
my brain said therein lies death step
off now wow even though it I mean it was
the most I've ever been injured in my
life broken uh later we found out it was
broken we didn't get my dad didn't
didn't I don't know maybe he did maybe
he was ashamed that he was the guy
saying no breaks this time but we didn't
go to a doctor until like a month later
and they said that that was that was
broken
if you would hit your head I think the
doctor said if you had hit your head you
would have died
wow your dad said no breaks
and he's like a safety guy so he he
[__] up
he [__] up real bad did your parents
really get divorced when you were seven
days old it's probably probably
somewhere between that and six months
they they were he definitely was
cheating on her oh cheating oh he's a
big cheater big cheater another thing
that's glorified in the mafia movies
he so so seven days six months I don't
even know exactly but before I was one
before I was cognizant so yeah
that's when I got divorced my mom
she I [__] up this story once and she
corrected me she listens I'm uh
and I I think she went to a party
and a woman there said I I don't mean to
be like don't shoot the messenger please
my husband met your husband and he
suspects and he's very intuitive he
suspects that he's cheating
and and my mom uh wait say what you just
said again
hi uh uh this woman comes up to your mom
yes hi Susan my husband make your
husband and you know oh maybe a cute
little story they went golfing together
are they going to be friends now yes I'm
so glad you're saying this again because
the first time I just didn't know
something amazing was happening and now
I do well that's what and and she's my
husband and he felt intuitive and felt
something and and my mom my mom said she
just like left she left the party
she that's why I might [__] up but
she called my dad she said
um
I saw you at dinner with another woman
this is a bluff I saw you at dinner with
another woman
and my dad said I'll be right home
and basically said uh this is
Sparta that's incredible it's incredible
it's incredible I saw you again not so
your mom is doing some assuming here not
only are you having an affair which we
can take but you go to dinner with these
women you know what I mean yeah yeah
that's not it could have been a hotel of
course but of course she is some
creative writing like I bet he's I bet
that son of a [__] is taking them out
to dinner and she had the restaurant and
everything and he said I'll be right
home and she never went back to the
woman said your husband is very
intuitive you're he was what a great she
never went she Shoulda yeah you're you
know probably upset about other things
at the moment
but
my my my dad just said he said uh this
is who I am I'm not gonna change
uh and and oh he didn't apologize
maybe you said I'm sorry I I don't know
my mom doesn't say oh he said a really
sweet apology but but just essentially
looking back at it now you're like oh
polyamory was for you papa uh instead of
whatever this [__] is but he he said
like I'm not going to stop essentially
he said like I want to have
women on the side essentially
do you think it was his love of Italian
stereotyped culture that his dad cheated
for sure just yes I don't want to use
the word sins but the old expression of
the father like it's yeah you learn it
you do it again
but I think what was different is like I
didn't know about the cheating until I
was much older my dad like did not the
women were in my life they were maternal
figures who disappeared but I never knew
him I didn't know I never knew that he
cheated so he had some women who would
leave abruptly and looking back now
knowing more information I'm like oh he
probably got busted for cheating but at
the time he just said oh well you know
Susan's she's had a tough upper turns
out Susan didn't like when I saw other
people but it's hard to know what to do
with it now I I feel like it's it's I
think of it like when they catch serial
killers like 50 years after they did the
crimes it's like well what do you do
they're dead it's a cold they're old
yeah yeah the time has punished them
enough
you know
the time has dealt out the sentence and
I don't know if it would have been
better if I would have known and could
have confronted him
but it's it's hard to know what the
information to do now what am I going to
be mad at him for being a horny 30 year
old I mean it is interesting and correct
you will you're a firm confident person
so correct me if I'm wrong but you're
fine you're such a Leo your father who
is
one of the Arbiters of your reality as a
young person was a lying cheating
unstable untrustworthy person
of course you don't believe in astrology
or UF you know what I'm saying like you
want
you want receipts you want documents you
want facts sure that's fine yeah when I
say that's fine is I'm not trying to
convince you to be like Sean Marco come
over here it's fun to think that maybe
this Stone if you touch it you win money
or whatever I'm not I don't care but
it's interesting I'll give you an
example like I know people I'm into
vedanta non-duality your experience with
mushrooms the Oneness it's also in
Judaism God is one that idea it's also
in a lot of religions when when the Bob
Marley folks say one love that's the
idea it's like this is one thing it's
hidden in culture one thing so I believe
that but I also grew up
for the whatever uh excuse me strange
issues I had
or whatever complications All Families
have I didn't
feel like the fundamental uh nature of
My reality was being jeopardized like it
was pretty regular uh-huh so of course
if you have that Foundation you can use
it to then go like maybe this is all a
dream like we're all just having this
weird Collective dream but if you had a
rocky thing where the page not the the
patriarch or or The Matriarch but these
again these Giants betray trust sure
you're not it's not as groovy for you to
be like and maybe this whole thing is a
Gaslight you know because you were
gaslit yeah I was yeah and I think and
it felt it felt good as a kid like my
dad was a he was the pillar he was he
was the strong one I went to my mom's
and my stepdad I didn't get along with
my stepdad as a kid so it's like my dad
was the figure so sure I I think I I
would say that like I know that
underneath that good feeling can be some
Sinister [__] and some some people be
mistreated even right and when my dad
had my little sister I mean part of the
truth is that East boy the [__] out of
me I was his his you know number one and
then my sister became number one and I
got to see what everyone else had to
experience when I must have been a kid
yeah especially the women he dated you
know and uh right he did also I mean
like when he dated a new woman he would
he would buy toys for them to give me
kind of like a dog you give him a treat
for the stranger visiting so so this new
woman would come into my life bearing
gifts
Santa wow what's not to love about this
new woman yes and then she becomes a
maternal figure and then one day gone
there's one there's one woman she uh we
used to play Monopoly together and and
what would happen these women they would
break up with my dad and then they would
have to have like a a breakup with me if
if they wanted to obviously and I
remember a very little kid she we were
sitting in the car a conversation in the
car conversation meant to end and then
one to leave
and and I said to her she said I'm gonna
be really busy at work so I won't be
around as much and I said like can we
are we still gonna play Monopoly and you
know she said we just take a beat
because that's heartbreaking yeah are we
gonna still play Monopoly as a
tear-jerker yeah I'm not delighting in
it I just want to pay that no I know
grief it's it's it's it's yeah it's
tough to do those moments in comedy
because he's talking about the premise
people just go like oh God yeah but I
actually yeah I hope to but that's what
you did on stage I think I could get
there but in this conversation at LOL
yeah
it's a tough sell uh and and then you
know she she lied essentially I put her
in a corner and she said some degree of
like yeah yeah
and then I'm still waiting still got the
Monopoly board set up the thimble's
waiting for the dog man yeah were you
the thimble
I think I was the little dog oh I think
I like the little dog my dog is my
mother so I never understand they need a
God piece but I think people would
complain
the god piece is it's just empty space
yeah
um wow interesting very interesting uh
and then oh sorry I I really do think we
touched on something there with the idea
it's like
how we view the Divine has so much to do
with our parents and just reality has so
much to do with our parents and you
it's interesting that you're
experimenting with mushrooms and you
want to do Ayahuasca because that is
like the it's a it's a real leap of
faith both of those things are leaps of
faith into something else and into our
unconscious and into our psyche and you
had this such an irregular upbringing
yeah I think it means that it sounds
like maybe you've done some healing I
think so for sure I mean therapy all the
things but I think like my girlfriend
and I it's it's been over two years now
and like
we there definitely felt a shift of us
really learning about each other's
parents and how they raised us usually
the the sadder things we'll get to the
positives eventually but but I I feel
like it's a a new level of closeness
yeah that that we're both in our 30s and
there's just like something about the
things I've learned about her parents
and the things I've been able to tell
her about mine that really is like are
they similar uh uh similar just her her
mom and my dad they were just some tough
times yeah I don't want to speak too
much for for him but but a degree of
like anxiety yeah anxiety uh uh uh
yelling
um and
and it's we're very similar we're you
know some relations I think it's very
opposite but we're very similar and we
both understand each other's anxiety
and just learning about each other's
parents
as you get older you're like [__] it
means so much your parents mean so much
to who you are and it's it's frustrating
yeah but it's interesting Val and I when
we were dating we uncovered all of these
like shared things and really what we're
talking about is shared experiences of
certain types of anxiety I think yeah
shared anxiety or a familiarity with the
things that make you anxious can really
become a powerful Alliance yeah because
if I know what makes you anxious I have
a pretty good guess on what makes you
comfortable sure you know what I mean
it's it'd be the opposite and that it's
almost like anxiety is like uh a tribe
or a religion or or an ethnicity that
you could share with somebody and you
have an allowance for it like some
people some people I overwhelm some
people for sure yeah for sure I
overwhelm some people yeah I'm I'm like
of filming a a set tomorrow for don't
tell and if I'm filming something the
week before I'm tough to be around and
I'm doing a lot of like hey would it
make sense if I change these two words
and they're like buddy I don't I don't
know what the difference is but
I am there for her when she's feeling
that yes she's there for me and there's
an understanding that's Valentine you
need to have a shorthand it sounds like
a great earmark of a relationship
because I I believe very firmly in
Valentine's relationship and you need to
be able to be like I'm having this thing
and if they understand that thing I just
say Val and I have been together long
enough I was like I just was in Toronto
two days ago was shooting something and
I just told her something that I said
and I was like was that okay and I just
go I'll just go like I just I know it's
okay I knew it was okay yeah I went I
just want you to tell me it's okay like
we'll just cut to it yeah I'll go like I
just need you to hear me and tell me
it's okay and she goes that's totally
okay and I'm like thank you yeah that's
that's anxiety yeah I go like there's
just too much bubbles back to hot tubs
there's too much bubbles on the hot tub
that means you got to put uh chlorine in
it just put a scoop of chlorine in my
anxiety tub and that's what we do for
each other or Val goes like I'm having
this feeling I go you're okay it's okay
we're okay yeah but I think I always get
my girlfriend sends me like relationship
Tick Tock so one was I'm like when
you're in a fight or not a fight if
they're feeling something ask do you
want like me to be a uh solution
oriented or just what is it a fix it or
a Feeling feel it yeah and like
I I often am because I'm like I want I
want both I want you to fix it and feel
it and make it right and be not
pandering to me yeah yeah and my mom is
like that prescriptive my mom's very
prescriptive there is just no but my
therapist is always like I don't want to
be prescriptive here because she doesn't
want to but then she does it anyway yeah
yeah but but uh my mom if I was feeling
sad I went through a bad breakup after
college and my mom her solution was just
like well how can you stop being sad and
I was like that's that's not happening
by the end of this phone call yeah yeah
so so so drop it but she that's her
being loving that's her her parents
right they didn't feel what's
interesting is yeah Val is a feel it and
I am actually pretty hard fix it and
it's hard for me to be a feel it all the
time
I mean look at the I'm obsessed with
Byron Katie and they're all these things
to like back things up like I'm upset
because this happened and you go but is
that true like my father is didn't care
okay we could do it with my story my dad
doesn't respect me because he came to
this show that I told him not to come to
is that true and I just go like it's not
true and that is actually how you love
me is is like let's fix it yeah I don't
necessarily need too much of like that
was really hard I do need some of it
yeah and I get that from Val but if I
were to choose between the two I like
when someone goes like so what did you
think that meant that your dad came or
could it mean that he loves you so much
he wanted to see you or whatever you
know instead of all these things we add
to it yeah so I can call [__] on
myself anyway so I I'm that way but when
people tend to tell me their problems I
really I'm like a dog on a chain I
really want to of course run in with the
technique yeah but and it's I mean but
then there's sometimes we we have that
similar anxiety where the when it gets
bad is one of both our anxieties like
meet each other well let's say we're
like our hypochondria can meet each
other sometimes where she'd be like do
you think this is something I'm like no
I think it's cancer like it's just like
it is it we both can't we we one of us
needs to be you know holding it together
yeah that's right yeah it's like waves
right and the best time is when you're
like a strand of DNA you know what I
mean and you're but when you meet in the
same you're both low at the same time
it's not a strand of DNA it's just a dip
and you're both in it yeah
Val and I have language for that too and
we just go like I think we're about we
say pain body we go we're both in our
pain body right now which means we're
insane yeah meaning overwhelmed I like
staying insane because it just means
you're you're not in your right mind
you're you're so overcome with your
emotions that it's like the best play
for us is to uh eat I don't mean like
overeat maybe we need some food sure
maybe we need some fresh air maybe we
need some exercise maybe we need some
sleep maybe we just need to watch uh an
episode of the office and just like
[__] cool out yes sometimes the only
thing you can do when you think every
mall is cancer is just go like maybe you
know that great thing where you go I
think we're being insane like if you get
paranoid when you're stoned like I think
we're paranoid that's my favorite thing
about being a human is the ability to
stop and choose again yes you know what
I mean like oh I think we've chosen the
wrong voice in our ad let's stop
that's why it's tough to be on the road
is when besides you don't have that you
can't have that moment of let's watch
something together let's eat something
together oh because you're talking if
you're distant and on the phone it just
everything becomes so limited yeah and
it's either you address it over the
phone or you take the space
and it can be tough I mean you you know
I don't have to tell you but it's like
It's just tough it is it's just I don't
it's a touch why I opt out it's a tough
life when when when I'm on the road Val
and I we'll we'll talk but like it's not
my favorite and she knows I think it's
just a highly sensitive person thing and
I'm not crazy about face timing I'm not
crazy I don't like FaceTime it's always
strange that there was no face it's like
why why would we do this I agree I I
agree it makes sometimes with kids the
kids go Dada is super fun yeah and Val
and I will do it because it is sweet to
see their face but after a while I'm
just like let's just talk when I get
home let's talk when I get home I agree
yeah I agree do you maybe think of that
White Lotus thing with the data remember
where he sees the sun that's not his
yeah but his wife had a kid with like
her trainer
did you ever catch that
oh no she had two kids and one of the
kids she implied was not her husband's
it was her trainer oh and there's a
scene oh you got you gotta watch it see
you know this and there's a scene I'm
embarrassed but I do want to say I'm
very tired
but he's flossing and you hear in the
background like Dad I get that she's
calling for him uh you know come here
come here and you see him flossing
really hard and then he comes in and he
like turns it on and goes hey buddy but
he knows that's not his son and that's
the price he has to pay for being a
cheater she he has a son that's not his
and he knows and they will never speak
of it it's that's very good she is so
patchy as she is so powerful in that
show what a great show what a great show
when it ended we had separation anxiety
we were like what do we do now it was my
every time we ended an episode because
it was very much about like gender and
like men and women yeah and after every
episode if Ellie wake up would be like
so what do you have to say for yourself
that's what was great about it yeah some
of the best fights so like the lesson
from it was kind of like
cheat a little
have a little bit of a you gotta [__]
well I think I hear you I think it's
saying because I just like I said I was
in Toronto I came home and I just had a
cast dinner right and that was I'm not
it's not cheating it's this like you
need Adventure one of the reasons so
your father was a cheater I'm saying one
of the reasons I feel like I will never
cheat is because my one because that's
[__] up but also because our lives are
novel like sometimes a dinner with other
grown-ups when you've been alone with
the baby for four days prior is like
this incredible White Lotus style
break-in routine sure and I said to Val
I was like I I hope you get she she was
just on this trip that's what I was
watching about you need disruption and
you and some people do it with naughty
but you can also do it with nice what am
I Santa Claus
well you know I'm just saying you need
break up your sleep schedule do
something you you don't normally do I
think the the day in day out same Monday
as same Tuesday as same Wednesday as
same thing that's where you you start
having Affairs and stuff and Val and I
were just talking about this there's
certain people in our Lives who are like
I was like I I joked to her I was like I
don't think my parents ever cheated on
each other but I sort of hoped they did
it would have been nice for them to
enjoy something sure it was just a joke
that's not really true but like you need
to find disruption that's more what I
took of course that's why cheating it's
like I also think we we live in a
society where there is this kind of hard
line between like you're either cheating
or you get a massage that's the closest
you're gonna get to like another person
just just to connect with someone
outside of it because in a way I could
see someone being like I don't want you
to get a massage it doesn't feel that's
not I know it's easy to think what
you're saying I'm getting a massage
every time I get a massage I'm like it's
and it's not a happy ending massage but
I'm like no they feel right on the edge
they're oiling you up they're oiling you
up there they're right up there my ass
they're interested in your pleasure it's
very it I'm not saying it's sexual I'm
saying it's sensual and not Central in
the sexual way but it's it's about your
senses and someone is considering your
pleasure and has actually gone to school
like to figure out what would feel the
best for you I got a happy ending
massage in Amsterdam a long long time
ago
99 of it's the same it was just the it's
the same it's all the same but at the
very end they flip you that's it oh my
God it's the same it that's ready to go
uh-huh
part A massages two schedule I
understand why someone would say don't
get one be your artistically looking
back on it where again this was I was
not in any kind of relationship but
there but there was a like oh this
doesn't feel like anything it feels like
I got a and it's scratched yeah I've
always wondered if we live in a society
where just hand jobs just handies yeah
you could go to the store and go oh I'm
stressed yeah I'm gonna run in here real
quick yeah I just wonder if the world
would be a better place
I think men especially just like there's
so so many things men do that like
if they just had an orgasm I don't I
think there's less gunshot after an
orgasm than before an orgasm well buddy
I used to have a bit about that I
stopped doing it I don't know why maybe
it was too dirty or something but I was
like I don't jerk off for me I jerk off
for you meaning like everybody else I
like that I was like I like that a lot
do you know how humiliating it is to be
like it's stupid but if I don't my bed
was like I'm too horny I'm too you just
have more testosterone in your blood
like sure after you have an orgasm you
have less testosterone so you're less
that edge yeah that's what I was
thinking about this today let me I'm not
even going to do it as a premise it was
just a thought I had driving in today I
was like
I agree you know how they say women are
as horny as men like that's like a new
thing meaning we weren't saying that in
the 90s sure we were like dudes are
horny and women kind of like are sort of
horny like that was as good as we got in
the 90s I will concede this is I'm not
even fully serious I just want to unpack
this with you women do get horny but
because they have typically I'm talking
very gender normatively less
testosterone that horniness is just
completely different look at uh lady
directed pornography it's like it's just
different it's it's software because
testosterone the thing that makes boys
again gender normally more boyish gets
mixed up in the horniness and it's a
completely different thing of course so
I'll give you you guys might be as horny
as us but you don't have the Nitro in
the tank that goes yeah that's what
we're talking about yeah I know you
might want sex but we want sex like and
it's mixed up in this like Conan the
Barbarian sort of
by the way as I'm saying this I just
want everyone to know I am joking and I
I can't call it how could I ever speak
for another gender or or any other group
for that matter uh the tweets on this
account I feel like a woman could see uh
two people fully clothed and it'd be so
hot and it's like a man I'm like take it
off yeah take off the clothes that's not
enough yeah that's right and that's what
a baby Arena let's get to the whatever
babe Arena
let's get to the wedding babe Merino
moment but I hate to be this like it's
like King of Queens level like
relationship Norms Val is when we have
like everyone every once in a while
we'll do it Val's way and it's all about
like keep the clothes on a lot longer
and uh more smooching that's very
classic it's hard to do I've tried to do
a bit with a degree where like you know
comedians would say women be shopping
and we know that's sexist yeah but now
that my girlfriend's moved in with me
sometimes I'm like they really do be
like she really do be shopping and I
don't know how to talk about it because
it's there's definitely some truth here
right that I what am I supposed to
pretend and when we and Val and I have
sex I'm like let's get naked immediately
I tried to do a bit I was like it's
about boners it's like I the boner is
here let's use it and women are like
keep it in the pants and I'm like what
if he goes away like it's almost from an
insecure place it's not from a secure
place sure I would go the guest of honor
is here uh-huh let's get him out and
they're like no there's more smooching
to be done I'm like okay but I might be
grinding on me with a flopping
it might be a floppy floppy disk I want
to win a three and five not a 5.25
uh-huh
I I did you get that disc riff I I young
to get that disc Griff I dyed discs for
like 3.5
and then the big floppy disk was a 5.2 I
remember the different size I don't
remember the ins it's inches yeah who
was it I know that's
that point of being a my dad said the
other day there's just something about
like you know he always he dates he
dates too young not not like not like I
understand oh my God but but like come
on man yeah and he just he said
essentially like you know I just I I
want to be really attractive because
it's it's not always easy working
downstairs and of course he's he's an
older he's an older man oh wait he wants
them to be attracted yeah so for him
he's like by the way his age he's not as
attracted and and and you know what well
I think what he can't handle the shame
of it yeah yeah I think what I liked
about what he said is that it wasn't I'm
not saying it's it's all not good but he
wasn't saying just I like him hot and
then titties bouncing it's part of like
he's like for me
he sees the legs guy he's more of like a
yeah
legs for days oh my God uh uh when did
the leg become a calendar yeah I've
never been a leg he would always just be
like look at her legs and I'd be like
okay
okay I'm with you can I tell you uh what
Freud would say about that one the baby
on the ground that didn't get picked up
likes the legs the baby they got picked
up got a lot of attack that's too funny
I love frogs
that's think about it what about the
baby on the who likes to the ass would
the mom sit on them that was on the
ground legs and ass are the same thing
ass is just top of the leg but why am I
an ass guy not a leg guy because because
you're like you're like let's just jump
to the final chord of the song legs are
like and then you're like is the booty
did Freud say that too he said that he
said
because cocaine [__] for sure but if
you got fed a lot and you were overloved
you're probably into boobies sure okay
by the way to bring some uh some uh
jean-mark skepticism I don't know if I
buy it I'm just telling you what I heard
sure sure
uh but the way that he phrased it it was
not just oh they need to be hot it was
that I need them I need them to be hard
to to do the thing I still want to do
yeah
um there's a movie called kernel
knowledge it's the only movie that Art
Garfunkel acts in it's Jack Nicholson
Art Garfunkel the whole point of the
movie is what you just said it's about
like the inability interactions how uh
emasculating shame induced thing all the
stuff it is for men and then they're
like and they date Anne Margaret and
Jack Nicholson goes when I saw her I
knew that would never happen again and
it's just it's just a movie about how
scared men are and that's what my bit
was trying to be I was trying to say
it's not because I'm a jerk that I want
to get to it it's because I'm I'm a
scared I'm a scared little boy and I
what the first the first person I lost
my virginity to I went through a phase
of not being able to anxiety yeah of
course overthinking I I it's gone too
quick and then I felt like us you know a
disappointment and I was like oh my God
it all and I I was too young I didn't
know go talk this out yes I mean I went
but I had to go to my stepdad I went to
my stepdad that's how bad it was like I
needed help because she was gonna leave
me I think at the time yeah so I was
reaching out to everyone so I had to
have like a conversation with my dad for
advice then my stepdad my stepdad he
took out a magazine with like a car with
a hot woman on it and so I said I'm like
you know I'm having trouble getting it
up or whatever and he takes up this
magazine this is how we're pressed he
goes like some men need to look at this
you know look at women like this to get
hard and that's no problem but you know
I have your mother
and and I don't think he meant it I
don't think he meant to like [__] me up
forever I don't think he met he wasn't
he wasn't like going like remember I
[__] your mom he was like trying I
have your mother something it was
something like that like I have your mom
but he meant I don't he meant this is a
good thing I think he meant like you
need to find
you what your mom is to me you need to
find for yourself
you know find someone as [__] that's
generous the way I get hard for your mom
go find somebody that's like your mom
but not your mom that gets you as hard
as your mom makes me he was saying
because he was in he even in the wanting
to help me he was trying to like be like
but I don't have a problem yeah of
course but I'm like but you're talking
to the son of the woman say it like this
where was the advice in that by the way
I don't know where was the help no there
was no help I feel like it's getting
worse I will it's funny because intimacy
like being able to talk I I used to have
a bit oh it's in a Batman video I go
sometimes the sexiest thing a woman can
do is forgive
because oftentimes that would happen
then she'd be like it's okay and then
I'd be like well now I trust you it's
very I thought you would relate to that
that's I think when I the beginning of
Comedy like my first stand-up bits were
about like that era and it's because I
had a one day I couldn't get it up and I
had a like breakdown and I started
sobbing I'd never stopped like that
before I woke up stopping like it was it
and I think it was because it was that
moment where maybe some men have it
later in life and this is why they go do
all these things where I was like my
body doesn't do what I wanted to do this
person says they love me but if I can't
give them this they're going that love
it doesn't mean anything right it is it
is predicated and in that moment with
the anxiety I go no one will ever love
me because I can't provide this thing
yeah yeah yeah and I truly think like
it's it was that break because that's
all I talked about in the comedy in the
beginning it was all just like you know
it was that moment talking about that
that relationship yeah and I think some
men maybe they Glide past that or they
don't and then at 50 it happens to them
and they go like right if I can't [__]
interesting I and I do think that's why
stand up there's there's something about
the achieving of stand-up that kind of
salves this to me it feels the similar
kind of worth uh shot it's a shot of
worth that has nothing to do with my
body I enjoy that I still more I I do a
bit where my girlfriend says you know I
don't want you to cheat on me and I'm
like that's fine but I want you laughing
at other men because it's like the same
it's it's the same area yeah you can
[__] them that's not let's go back to
massages that's why hecklers tend to be
men because it's like you're making
they're not sure you're making my date
you're titillating my date like what are
you doing yes yeah it's not always
that's that's more like a 90s I said a
heart once I was let's say I just saw a
couple and this woman said like I drove
three hours and they were on like their
second date I said something like how
does it I said at the guy how's it feel
to meet the man that she actually wants
to sleep with Wow and I was just [__]
around for the moment I said it I was
like I think if I came from somewhere
too close I think that came from
somewhere something that I'm getting
from this yeah but it's your job to take
risks yes good for you they they left he
didn't hit me but good but uh yeah where
are we at time I mean like what time is
it okay I think we have to go just
because my lovely neighbor postponed
their their housework so we could do
this podcast that's very nice that's
right I didn't think it was gonna work I
was like I have a podcast she was like
we'll stop till three so very nice
that's the first time your neighbors
found out you have a podcast yes I don't
think she knew oh here we are that's
nice so can you tell me the time you've
laughed the hardest in your life it's
weird we we got this like second wind I
feel like we could go another hour
easily it's very lovely but um a second
wind meaning like we had like such a
initial charge and then we got another
one and that never happens
where was the deal I cut out the dip
where was the dip
Dollar Store Melanie uh can you tell me
the time you laughed the hardest in your
life
um
sure
I I feel like I I don't I don't know
what the moment is that because it
wasn't a specific moment but my my
oldest sister she's my half-sister
but we used to have moments as kids
she's exactly four years younger
um we have the same birthday and we
would have moments where we would just
start laughing
and it we would just like start laughing
with each other and I think it's because
we were in an unhappy household yes uh
her her father and our mom yes and there
was some kind of tension release of like
we are prisoners in this this
emotionally [__] up parent this is
looking back at the time we would just
laugh yeah and and and I I think we'll
always have this connection of until I
had two other siblings born on that side
but there was just a time where we
we were the first she was the first of
her parents I was the first of my
parents yeah and we had something of
like we are in a [__] up place yes and
we would just laugh and laugh and I we
we haven't had it but I I just remember
that feeling
um and I always
because she has full siblings and I I
think there's always a part of me that
goes I don't know how they view me and I
don't have any full siblings so I don't
know what that would be different from
what we have I was a visitor I would be
at that house and then I would go to my
dad's and they would have to they would
have to bear the brunt of that for their
whole and the good yeah and uh I think
despite being sometimes on Shore or am I
a good enough brother to them how do
they view me I know that my oldest
sister and I we shared something before
the others were born where we were just
the only two children in the house and
then we'll always have those laughs
those laughs those are like sacred
laughs or something and necessary laughs
yeah that you really like carried you
through life blood laughs yeah I love
that answer we've had a lot of like
funny stories but that is like such a
great I know exactly what you're talking
about there's a beautiful answer yeah
well I really feel like we could talk
for three like I I haven't had one in a
while where that's not to put down the
other guests what am I why
this is well this is the one where I'm
like I could easily talk to you for two
more hours and love it so please check
out your podcast what's it called again
the downside the downside and check out
your special uh there's a special called
shelf life on Amazon and uh and I'll
have a don't tell set coming out soon
that I'm very proud of I love that well
thank you very much would you say keep
it crispy you can say it as Jean Marco
and then say it as Dollar Store Melanie
you have to do this of course oh and
then a Jeff Goldberg yes
um okay uh keep it crispy
uh was that you yeah oh if you're like
[__] God damn it keep it crispy very
good and then uh hmm keep it crispy I
didn't tell you my story yes real quick
yes batic Sage Largo me Nick Kroll Jeff
Goldblum we played five degrees of Jeff
Goldblum with Jeff Goldblum
like Kevin Bacon but with him yeah and
it's even less with Jeff he's been
around and he was going
oh maybe it was six but he would go like
and someone would go like blah blah and
he goes and uh was in Jurassic Park with
uh Jeff Goldblum he pointed to himself
I tell you when he gets mad something
happens yeah something happens nobody
wants to say umhf Goldblum very angry
ah no no no
um thanks pal thank you wonderful
[Music]